stuck in the north hold me up bro step
bro
step bro
i'm stuck oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
hello you terrific thoughtful
tremendously talented teens and welcome
to the trash case episodes
so i just wanted to beat joey's
alliteration
now i know how [ __ ] stupid it sounds
wait did you think it sounded naughty
how did
so yeah welcome to the trash taste
podcast i'm your host for today gant and
with me again are the boys joey and
connor that's me that's awesome yes
how's your week been guys it's been all
right i mean we should be asking you
that yeah yeah yeah because you had uh
oh we're here on a thursday yeah okay we
are here on a thursday okay so i know
you couldn't tell
so no i know i've not been uh putting
trash taste on the best of records
recently you know we've put the streams
uh we've delayed the streams two weeks
because uh i unfortunately got covered
and now we've had to delay the stream
for two days now
because i got stuck in a snowstorm
because i was up in hokkaido i can't get
a doll
i am playing gatron life and i am losing
on every [ __ ] role i swear to god um
but no that's exactly how it felt
because i was up in uh i was up in
hokkaido just on a trip just on a trip
with me in sydney for like a good like
four or five days yeah and we were
scheduled to come back on the monday
yeah and if anything happened on the
monday i could have come back tuesday
morning to record trash taste because my
entire life is planned around trash days
recordings i'm sure you're your guys are
livestreams now pretty much yeah um and
unfortunately on
on monday i woke up and checked my
flight my flight was canceled i was like
all right whatever it's hokkaido we can
expect that to happen sometimes um i
look on the site to rebook my flight
and every single flight for the entire
day is just cancel council council
council council council cancelled um so
how bad was the storm it was really
really [ __ ] bad it was like
i've obviously not had much experience
in like cold weather and snow yeah so
this was the first time
this was the first time i'd ever been
like i guess caught in a snowstorm and i
remember um i remember when like during
the snowstorm we had to take a taxi to
the airport because um all of the trains
had stopped running so it wasn't just
planes we were we were looking at oh can
we take you know the shinkansen or the
train back from hokkaido to tokyo nope
everything everything was gone which
says a lot with hokkaido right because
like hokkaido is one of those places
where it snows so often yeah even like
just like a little bit of snow or like a
substantial amount of snow it's still
like yeah we'll just power through it
yeah unlike tokyo where it's like 10
centimeters of snow stop the trains stop
everything bro the uk can't imagine man
the uk can't imagine right i remember we
we like constantly go through grit
shortages in the uk because we're just
so ill prepared for just the tiniest bit
of snow they always do this the exact
same speech every time
they were like why aren't the buses
running the buses were running during
world war ii and now they've stopped
because of a bit of snow what is this
but they do this every single time right
yes they say how dare the buses stop the
absolute state it's like what what
because another country attacks or
because nature attacks yeah what do you
think is scarier nature
definitely yeah so i remember like i
remember during the snowstorm um i had
to go outside for just a few seconds um
to go to to go from my hotel front door
to the taxi in the road in front of me a
simple one to two minute walk you know
ever we've all done it and i remember
thinking it's just a bit of snow it's
just a bit of wind i've handled that
before i go out and then i've never felt
like nature's just like beating the [ __ ]
out of me just as soon as i stepped out
the door right
because like this snow i'm like i've
felt snow before it's like it's you know
i felt snow before it's soft it's fluffy
it's soft it's fluffy enough this snow
was like [ __ ] ice man yeah like the
wind had turned this soft fluffy snow
into like an into like a [ __ ] wmd or
something like that
like my face literally like i felt like
my face was like getting cut from like
the brief moment that i didn't have my
hood up the weekend album
yeah yeah
yeah and so and seeing you caught in
like a pokemon attack yeah yeah
basically it like this was literally
just blizzard
i could feel like the hail just like
[ __ ] beating the [ __ ] out of my face
that 120 power point
oh like and it was even worse for sydney
as well because for some reason uh
sydney decided that she shouldn't bring
any footwear to hokkaido other than
heels so i mean it was like it was like
boots right but it was like boots with
like heels on them yeah yeah um that's
uh like yeah i know i know i know you
know
what was she expecting up in hokkaido
i think it's just been so long since
she's seen snow right that she has
forgotten what you know other
well other environments it's like
wisconsin right doesn't it snow like a
[ __ ] up always yeah it does it
does because i was i was just like i
remember asking her oh i remember
telling her oh i've never seen like snow
like this in my life and she was like oh
it's been a long time and i was like so
it's been a long time for you and yet
you are still so
less prepared you're so prepared for
this weather
um but yeah i mean we just weren't
obviously we weren't expecting it to uh
be that harsh yeah the weather
conditions would be that hard so hard um
and yeah we had to stay in hokkaido
basically we were living out of an
airport hotel for two days uh because we
woke up the next day uh we i remember
because i messaged these guys uh guys
we're gonna have to possibly delay the
recording by like an hour or two maybe
i'm gonna get an early flight it's all
gonna be good it's only like the weather
forecast it's only scheduled for the
snow to be really bad on this day i wake
up i look out my window uh the
blizzard's still [ __ ] going
and i'm like guys the guys okay we okay
i can make it back i swear to god i can
make it back the flight's on cancel yeah
the flight sign council yeah and i
remember like trying to like reorganize
with these guys to be like okay i'm
gonna make it back on this hour i can
make back of this to the studio at this
hour we can record we can still stream
yeah it's all good it's all good it's
fixed guys we can still do trash days
yeah um and an hour passes and then
every flight is cancelled again
and in in the
the defeated manner boys guy and going
like sorry boys i'll let you down i'll
let you down boys i'll let you down it
wasn't so much you that let us down it
was the [ __ ] weather yeah like it
wasn't your fault
yeah and just fight through it yeah just
walk back just walk back it's walkable
yeah because like because like we've
been through hokkaido like a few times
before yeah and like i swear to god it
just like like sweating on every time
you go to hokkaido you're playing gacha
with the planes
right because a lot of planes get
cancelled like very frequently right
obviously not as not in this kind of
state where like literally the entire
airport was shut down but you're
normally playing gacha when you go to
hokkaido because one or two planes will
normally get cancelled or rescheduled or
like heavily heavily delayed but then
that's when you discovered why
airport which is the airport in hokkaido
is so well equipped right right yeah
yeah it is actually like chitose airport
is like one of the best airports
i've been to in the world i think just
just i mean just with like how many
restaurants and how many like resources
are there there's basically like a
shopping mall inside the airport yeah
yeah basically because like
because like the airports that stick out
to me are airports like singapore
airport yeah which is just that that's
like an amazing airport like uh the
hokkaido airport is more like
that's that's more like a shopping mall
with an airport attached to it yeah yeah
yeah where most because most of the
stuff you see is before you go into the
departure zone whereas most airports
like it's the departure zone which
really has all of the restaurants all of
the shops and all the everything but
yeah in chitosa i mean there's even like
a uh there's even like a cinema there as
well yeah which uh there were there was
yeah yeah yeah i don't know yeah i mean
if you watch something i didn't the only
film they were playing was uh the jiu
jitsu tyson movie do this just go watch
it just go watch it i mean i i i i am
actually gonna go watch it this weekend
which is which is the only reason why i
didn't watch it when i was in
hokkaido um but yeah i mean i mean it
wasn't it wasn't too bad because of the
airport there luckily i was able to get
an air uh get a hotel at the airport
um it was just more annoying because
obviously i wanted to be back i wanted
to be working
um but yeah i mean that was there's not
there's not really much to say about it
i mean like i'm sure this is like every
other day for a canadian yeah i like i
remember like there's going to be a
million [ __ ] people in the comments
being like
imagine living with sort of that every
day of the week
yeah it was just weird just like because
i'm just used to no matter what happens
there's always kind of like a plan b
that you can fall back on a possible
plan b um but it was just the roads were
closed airports were closed trains were
closed so i was literally like stranded
you basically experienced quarantine
yeah yeah basically yeah
i was basically stranded at the airport
and there was no plan b there wasn't
there was no services i could call to
get myself out of there to a place where
i could get some public transport to
tokyo because did you go around uh
getting the shopping carts to get some
money together so you could buy a burger
it's
collecting
plastic cans oh yeah so yeah so yeah i
basically just lived the terminal except
[Music]
sorry unfortunately i wasn't tom hanks
because like i think one of the craziest
like weather phenomena i've been caught
up in was uh when i was in vegas and
they have dust storms there
dust storms yeah so basically just think
of a sandstorm but instead of the sand
coming in from i've never even been in
the sandstorm right well i haven't been
in a sandstorm but i've been in a dust
storm and it happens pretty frequently
the difference between sand and dust uh
i i don't i thought it was a sand storm
at first right but then everyone all my
friends were like oh it's a dust storm
coming and it's like a different
vernacular maybe or it's like maybe it's
not just sand maybe it's like sand and
all the crap like mixed into it but
basically
i was like i i was driving around in uh
in vegas you know just with a bunch of
friends and then like on the radio
because he had the radio on he just like
suddenly switches on and he's like oh
there's a dust storming coming um so
please you know please evacuate kind of
thing and i was [ __ ] my pants i was
like what the [ __ ] is a dust storm
and then uh but everyone else there the
locals just like oh yeah it happens
pretty frequently let's let's just go to
like a restaurant get something to eat
so uh so we we go into this restaurant
and then the dust storm hits and it's
like just yeah just think of like a
typhoon right so it's like just really
insane winds
but
you can't see outside like the whole
windows are like like nothing it's just
like all sand it's just like like it's
like a blizzard but instead of white
it's just like grayish brown it's like a
survival game yeah but what's more
terrifying in my opinion than a blizzard
is the fact that uh in a dust storm
it can cause static electricity oh so
basically you have like thunder strikes
at ground level
because of all the particles rubbing
together right so every now and then
it'll just be like blowing and then
you'll just hear this like boom sound
from outside and i'm like the [ __ ] is
happening it's like oh that's just the
electricity
it's like why are you saying it like oh
yeah that's just my friend like you know
like saying it so casually yeah um
yeah so that's really interesting yeah
so that entire time i was [ __ ] my
pants while we were in this uh
we're in this ramen shop because of
course they were like oh joe's japanese
let's just go to a japanese restaurant
i'm like yeah
yeah i'm here all the way in vegas to go
eat some japanese sub-par japanese food
all right so we were so basically i was
stuck inside a ramen shop called naruto
are you serious i'm not even fronting
it was called naruto they have like
naruto like uh i mean they did that
oh yeah like the walls had like naruto
yeah and like i thought you could have
been named after the location no no no
it was uh and and the ramen it was very
obvious they tried to replicate the
naruto ramen as best as they could right
to you know to to
not that great levels admittedly i think
it was the most three out of ten ramen
i've ever had so i was like great i'm
stuck inside this [ __ ] restaurant
called naruto eating at this poor
restaurant getting destroyed i don't
think it exists anymore yeah so someone
if it does exist sorry
most perfect moment of like the locals
going this guy's japanese he likes anime
so i got the perfect one i saw the
episode and simpsons when they go to
america town in japan yeah yeah
basically
dude i mean the first thing the first
thing i ate when i went to america for
the first time which was the first ax i
ever went to my friends [ __ ] took me
to little tokyo and i was like bruh
everybody yeah every time you i've got
an ax everyone's got a little turkey
and then i had again some subpar ramen
and a little tokyo i was like yeah great
the fan this is the la experience i
wanted the only time i've ever seen a
natural phenomenon of what those uh i
saw sun in the uk one time
you were like oh i was like what the
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] i've seen fire tornadoes in
australia what the [ __ ] is a fire truck
we have it is in the uk
so you have tornadoes yeah and you have
bush fires yeah so what happens when a
tornado enters a bushfire
you basically get this spiraling like
pillar of fire that's it
it's [ __ ]
awesome to look at from a distance
these like u.s settlers must have been
so [ __ ] confused
when all this [ __ ] was happening they
were like what the [ __ ] is happening i'm
pretty sure that's what the british saw
the first time yeah
what the [ __ ] is that
the first time they found like the swamp
in florida they're like what yeah it's
like
a bit humid in here
like australia is just like a real life
island in one piece
it is an island on the ground line at
this point you know because like the
survival instincts you need in this
island like that that's taking out most
the [ __ ] pirates in one piece at this
point imagine being the guy who has to
like write the guide that they send back
to like people are going to come again
it's like so so by the way you're not
going to believe this right you know how
it's sun sometimes right yeah it's like
that all the time all the time and
sometimes i don't know how this happened
it was just by a tornado i don't know
what a tornado is we've never seen one
of those yeah this is a tornado
it says but it's such a weird thing as
well because it's not like uh i i kind
of described it like there's a bush fire
and then a tornado comes along and like
eats up the fire it's also like the fire
is so strong that it basically creates
an up current that starts to spin and
then it just creates like this pillar of
fire
that just like crashes through this just
sounds really cool to see it just sounds
like a [ __ ] anime attack at this
point
like well like like i was like i was
like is there a pokemon battle happening
over there like someone did firespin i
don't know like it's like two jitsu's
being combined together in naruto you
know it's like
stomach after having that narration
yeah i mean i did i did see actually
there recently like the uk or at least
london went through like a pretty bad
storm yeah yeah yeah um which i like i
don't know how bad it was because like
when i when i see i want to see like uk
really bad it looked really bad because
like when i see but like you know when
you see uk headlines yeah you see like
oh uk go through like a bad storm like
the strongest wind scene and i'm just
like well
is it like obviously it's going to be
bad for the uk but like how bad is it on
a global scale there is videos of it
picking up people and throwing them oh
seriously yeah yeah yeah
yeah because when i saw that headline i
thought it was just like the british
over exaggerating it no dude as you guys
usually just like oh my my friend's 2p
fell off it's an absolute travesty like
it's so strong
i saw some videos people get thrown
around i was like oh my god
like like rip if you're trying to open
that car door man yeah trying to get
that close
yeah because like this okay so like this
just shows how unused we are to this
these kind of like weather systems and
weather phenomena right because like we
um we're like me and connor in like a
group chat of like our friends back in
the uk um and sometimes you know they're
still meeting up and they're still
planning meetups and everything like
that and i saw in this group chat that
they had planned a meet-up or to hang
out on this day
and i remember like right up to like the
last moment people were just like oh
yeah i'll see you guys in an hour i'll
see you guys now right we're still
meeting in an hour and people like yeah
yeah i'll see you in an hour and then
you just see you just see this the
replies going yeah let's maybe not meet
up today maybe that's not the best idea
but like the thing is if this was like
one of the worst storms that uk has gone
has gone through like i'm i am also
really used to the idea that no matter
what you can still go out and have a
pipe yeah you can still go out and have
a point no matter what yeah the pub has
been canceled so like that's how i knew
that this storm was like the real deal
yeah if my mates were not going to the
pub to meet up because of this storm you
know shit's gone down if the pub isn't
closed then that means i can still go
yeah
no matter what
it is basically that
[Laughter]
oh god yeah that is uh another episode
of uh uk people
severely unprepared for you know weather
systems yeah because like i remember
you know when i first met my first like
you know british person like from the uk
yeah exist yeah they exist i was like oh
my god you guys exist but second of all
you know they're always like oh yeah we
have nothing going on in the uk like no
bad weather no like dangerous animals no
nothing i'm like really like really like
i i found that hard to believe as
someone who came from the polar opposite
of that yeah from doom just yeah i came
from doom i came from hell basically
the underwater
yeah because it's like do you guys
really not like what is the most like
dangerous thing floods okay yeah i was
about to say we got a lot of rivers so
obviously when it rains a lot it can
flood but yeah depends on what depending
on where you are in the uk there aren't
floods like what if you're like nowhere
near like the rivers yeah then you don't
get anything
occasionally you guys get a lucky yeah
yeah we've had hurricane scares before
at least in my lifetime but nothing that
actually like manifested anything felt
like a hurricane right yeah it was just
a bit of strong wind yeah yeah
yeah that's that's pretty much it yeah i
mean we don't have a lot to fear in the
uk which is why whenever i travel abroad
um whenever i uh sorry i lost my trail
of thought uh whenever i travel aboard
uh
all aboard
whenever i travel abroad i got it i got
it this time
sometimes it just like surprises me um
about some of the things you have to be
careful of just because in the uk we
don't have to be careful of anything
like you know with camping you have to
be careful about bears or you know
starting a forest fire which to me like
starting a forest fire was like so
outside my perception of walk of like
disasters that could happen just like
one person but like
if you think about it yeah of course it
makes sense you know you see you look at
australia being on fire california like
half the year being on fire yeah like
our country was on fire for nine months
straight because of one guy starting a
fire yeah yeah yeah to me like that just
like that's just so outside of my
perception of what could [ __ ]
possibly go wrong of one like one stupid
person doing like a stupid thing you
know yeah so yeah i mean all the trees
are like wet in the uk it was very hard
to
get even i remember when we were camping
it was even hard to get like trees that
weren't too dense
to burn
yeah i mean you could you could come in
with like a [ __ ] flamethrower and
it'll probably be put out by the day the
flamethrower will run out of gas
[Laughter]
yeah i've ever seen anywhere like in
nature on fire in the uk really
no fire is just not like it's hard to
get started yeah yeah it's very hard to
get nature fires aren't like a thing
that we have to be careful about and
yeah one of the biggest uk hits was
firestarter so you know that's a bit
ironic isn't it because they they had so
much time while they were making the
fire starter yeah um they yeah part of
yourself make a song about it
you do the fire on me
that's why it's an achievement right
yeah like it's easy to be a fire starter
anywhere else in the world in the uk
it's it's a medal i'm a firestar i was
like damn
does he manage that
i want some forest fires like natural
like this that needs to happen sometimes
to clear a lot of the like dead trees
yeah yeah yeah so obviously a lot of
them recently are like not yeah so we
have we have uh controlled bushfires uh
in australia that happens like pretty
frequently um because we also have uh i
don't know the the details about it but
we have this specific uh like
is it breed i don't know i don't know
what the word for it is of tree or like
sapling uh where
uh
it's type of eucalyptus i think where
the the the seeds from the tree
need to be
put into a fire in order to open up
so to keep the forest alive they
actually have to burn these seeds and
basically start a bush fire for that
area of the bush land to grow in
which is like which is the most like
backwards thinking that nature has ever
done it's like so imagine if like the
dead trees pile up and then it's as hot
as it is in australia yeah it'll
naturally catch up oh yeah we got
natural bushfires all the [ __ ] time
just because of how hot and powerful
australia literally is like the last
dungeon area like even nature is high
level in australia like what they're
doing like randomly just start fighting
it's literally the desert level of time
the breath of the wild
it's literally a desert level in breath
of the wild where like if you don't have
the right equipment you are forever like
just gaining damage from this yeah i
think in israel i think it's well i
can't remember i might have been one of
those generic vox videos where you learn
about [ __ ] you didn't know you wanted to
learn about and then you learn about it
and you're like okay you're in every
youtube video no mainly vox videos
youtube shorts always like that so so i
think it was like
because the us for so long was
actively stopping all the fires
it turned out that a lot of the branches
needed to just be set ablaze so that
they could get rid of them and then it
could go back in the system you know it
turns into ash so they had like a build
up of a lot of dead uh dead trees and
stuff like that so when the fire did
start it went like crazy yeah nearly as
big as it was i mean like yeah we think
i could be wrong on that yeah i mean we
have like so many like controlled
bushfires just because we do have like
just at least in my area we have a lot
of like wildlife and like nature
reserves and stuff like that but you
know sometimes unfortunately they're not
you know some of those fires aren't
controlled 100 of the way and that's
what causes bushfire scares and straight
up bushfires sometimes so i think that's
why we have a lot of that
just because we're trying to maintain
the nature and then sometimes nature's
like you know what i'ma go ham a little
bit
and then they go ham only controlled
fire in the uk is from trying to boil
your water
oh god
help as an australian what is like your
biggest fear over there in terms of like
nature or
nature-wise um like what you have to be
careful about the motion
yeah honestly the people scare me the
most
that's such a video game movie thing
yeah it's not the animation worry about
kids it's the people it's the people
humans are the scariest of them all
the humans were the monsters
you can predict a black widow can't
predict a human
guns don't kill people
people kill people
um in terms of wildlife like i'm usually
pretty okay with like insects and like
snakes and spiders if i know it's not
going to kill me have you ever had like
a big scare yourself of like you've
encountered something you're like oh
this could this [ __ ] could actually oh
yeah yeah many times like i've i've
thought the health bar comes on the
whole part of the screen
yeah many times like uh i remember
i was actually this close to
basically dying at one point uh because
i was this close to being bitten by uh
bitten by one of the most venomous ants
in the world
yeah
so we're not only so australia so people
outside of australia think that
australia is just like yeah venomous uh
spiders and snakes
yeah we have a lot of uh venomous
insects and we have this one ant uh
species called the bulldog ant
and uh it is
supposedly the most venomous ant in the
world and i almost got bitten by one
when i was like 10 years old right i
think
like dark souls is like way more
balanced than australia at least it has
like a hitbox you can see so basically
yeah so basically like i was i was
camping uh you know that's where most of
the accidents happen you got the
campfire right that makes sense yeah no
i was i was camping on fire and i was
like sitting here
before i could teleport um yeah so i was
like kind of sitting around the fire
with uh you know my family my mates and
uh i was like maybe 10 11 years old and
we were in like a really really like
deep rainforest area right yeah so it
was like you know basically we just
found like a fl it wasn't even like a a
registered campsite basically it was
just like oh we found a flat piece of
ground yeah let's just you know start a
fire here you know as long as there's
control that's what it is
i like the way he just said responsible
yeah
he didn't say let's let's make this our
campsite yeah yeah that's not a fire
yeah i mean i've been a responsible fire
yeah yeah a small fight let's start
let's start a fight here let's let's
let's let's honk it down here for the
night all right yeah let's uh so we set
up the camp there and you know my dad
started the fire and you know we were
getting all cozied up and uh i was
sitting on this like giant slab of rock
right right it was like very smooth and
you know as like a 10 year old you just
want to like climb [ __ ] right it's like
you know i found lots of little rocks to
like and big rocks to kind of climb
around in and i was sitting and i was
kind of sitting with my mate as well and
my hand was like rested back like this
right okay kind of like legs out right
kind of thing
and i was just chilling and everything
and then i felt
something crawl onto my hand right
and i looked down and it was an ant
but i was like oh that's a that's a big
ant well how big we talking um like like
that that's quite big yeah that's pretty
i mean that's still an ant yeah you know
it's still an air
this pitch black ant uh just kind of
like crawling onto my finger
um and then uh yeah and then i kind of
like put my hand up and was looking at
it and then my friend who was next to me
just gasped and then [ __ ] immediately
swatted my hand away and swatted this
ant off me right and i was like what the
[ __ ] i was looking at this cool land
why would you do that and he was like
dude you could have died like you do
know what that thing is right and then
he told me and he showed me uh what it
was i was like
well thank you for slapping my hand um
glad i didn't die yeah does it
definitely kill you or is it like i mean
it's like it's like it can kill it they
say the venom is powerful enough to like
kill an adult in like 15 minutes so as a
10 year old uh probably would have been
like instantaneous was the uh coyote
peterson video of him yeah right
yeah yeah
i already know he will kill me
that's the next level of bomb
it's like
it's like in the og youtube days it's
like will it blend
like 20 30 youtube will i die if i die
will i die let's find out i'm going to
be this i'm about to enter the death
zone
with the bulldog
yeah so uh yeah so basically my my
friend saved my life and uh now i'm
now i know that we have these ants
because you know
yeah when you're because you know when
you're a kid in australia you know
you're always you know told like
you know be careful of the snakes be
careful of the spiders because you know
we do have a lot of non-venomous kinds
yeah but you know that's not the ones
you have to look out for obviously like
you know i've been bitten by snake once
but it wasn't venomous it just really
[ __ ] hurt right so that i mean that's
fine it was just like a little nip on
the finger so it's whatever um you know
what doesn't kill you what doesn't kill
you makes you stronger right they must
have sent the craziest [ __ ]
from the uk
if i was if i was like there one of the
first people in australia and my friends
just just gets bitten by an n and we're
like laughing jovial and then he just
dies like we're leaving
[ __ ] this play get back on the boat
we're leaving
oh a little cute little lamp
just like [ __ ]
that's when you play the ground is lava
you know like it's like everybody off
the ground yeah the dark history
yeah i don't think i'd have like the
courage to do anything in australia
because like there's no [ __ ] the more
i read the more i'm just like well i
just i guess i just won't go outside
it's great the beaches sound great until
i read about like [ __ ] stone fish
right and then i'm just like oh i mean
it's a stone fish just you know just
don't [ __ ] step on the way
okay so a stone fish is a fish that
looks exactly like a stone it's very
ugly fish it's a very like a bottom
dweller yeah but it's fins have
razor-sharp needles that if you step on
it it's apparently one of the most
painful like experiences you can have
from an animal yeah from an animal have
any of your friends stepped on one uh
i've had a friend step on one uh
and uh he oh i mean he obviously went to
the [ __ ] hospital for he didn't die
but
well that's a plus but i mean he didn't
die
painful it's just extremely painful i
mean if you it could cause like
anaphylactic shock and like kill you if
you're unlucky you know like like
yeah it's the most famous fish known on
earth um and so even if i don't even if
you don't die you're going to have a
very very bad time yeah you're just
gonna experience a lot i mean if you're
experiencing enough pain what's the pain
is it because it's sharp or is it like
got some poison probably got some toxins
in it or something right
yeah it will kill you
it can kill you okay just like pull up
the glock shoot your own foot yeah
stop it stop her from going through this
cut it off
i mean like you know i think but like
things like stone fish and like you know
are they super common or is it super no
it's very very rare this video is
sponsored by harry's as you guys know i
am a sigma male and the only thing i
will allow to touch my sigma male beard
is harry's i actually only use harry's
i'm not kidding i've said this like
every single harry's ad read i bought a
bunch in the uk when i came here and i
still use harry to this day well then
you'll be happy to know connor and
everyone watching this video that new
customers can redeem a harry's trial set
forget this
three dollars three dollars three
dollars when you go to harrys.com
harry believes you shouldn't have to
choose between a close comfortable shave
and a fair price so they give you both
in fact harry's blades are designed to
stay sharper for longer in a recent
study guys who shave four times a week
said that eighth shave was as smooth as
their first well dear viewers and
listeners today is your lucky day new
harry's customers yes can redeem us
start a set yeah you get five blade
razor a weighted handle yeah foaming
shaving gel with alloy with our and a
travel cover to protect your blades when
you're on the go that's 13 value boys
for three dollars oh there's truly never
been a better time to try harry's go to
harry.com slash trash taste to try
harry's today back to the video one
thing you mostly have to worry about if
you go to the beach in australia is the
jellyfish i was going to say the second
thing that [ __ ] terrifies me we have
a ton of those jellyfish not toxic
jellyfish though oh but the ones that
are like extremely painful oh yeah yeah
i mean because like we you're probably
seeing a box jellyfish right yes okay
yeah like i've never seen that in the
waters i've never heard of anyone
getting stung by that but like that's
the one that can kill you yeah and
whatever people have yeah where it
puts you in so much pain that you drown
because you have zero control over your
body yeah it basically paralyzes you
immediately have people like survived uh
people have survived yeah but a lot but
i mean like it's it's a very uncommon
way oh sorry it's a very rare way for
anyone to like i think only like maybe
like two or three people die a year from
it or something so it's like it's very
very rare considering the amount of
people who go into the ocean in
australia like it's you've got to be
really unlucky fish jellyfish just scare
me yeah but i mean like i've been stung
by the other kind of jellyfish that's
way more common is they call blue bottle
jellyfish and they're not they're not
toxic or anything like they won't kill
you but it hurts a lot when you get
sunburned yeah my friend got stung by
when we were swimming in the in like
some shitty ocean yeah
okay and and the trick in australia is
if you have a mate who's been stung by a
blue bottle you you pee on pee on that i
think this is one of those rumors though
isn't it
it's just one of my jojo fans all right
i don't think it actually i think i
think the actual way to do it is like
you got to like pour vinegar or
something on it but it means
having your mate piss on you feels
relieved yeah it's not it's
when you say it out loud it does feel
like a scene from jojo yeah
you've been stung by a stand the only
thing
gordon experience
36 degrees right there dog like that
that's warm as [ __ ] this is why this
isn't a problem in the uk everyone's
always got a hot furnace ready for the
tea their bodies are just like get the
tea thermos
this could make it worse actually oh
really depending on how i see what's uh
sorry for peeing on your leg that one
time
i remember we were swimming and a bunch
of a bunch of the jellyfish is washed up
yeah oh that's normal yeah i've i've
seen that in the uk as well
bunch of them washed up and this little
ten-year-old didn't know what they were
mm-hmm
i think i was twelve dived into it yeah
just like picked one up
well you can you can pick them up by the
head yeah i know you picked it up by the
way
yeah that's probably immediately started
crying and screaming and then oh [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] that i remember there was
loads of them i remember i got really
freaked out because i was like what the
[ __ ] is that yeah this is not how they
were in finding nemo that's what i
remember
i think there was any journey fishing
weird fish yeah
yeah that wasn't that jellyfish but what
fish freak me out so much more than like
animals do like what is fishing on
animals
no fish fish right animals are animals
yeah jellyfish isn't an animal i know
it's an animal but [ __ ] like coffee like
what the [ __ ] is going on with fish i
mean it doesn't have a brain injury
jellyfish is just god's spunk
that's just what they are like fights
back
i mean like that's the closest way
is the ocean sperm cell
you look at you know that mr incredible
meme where he's like smiling and
gradually getting like more sound yeah
he's like you look at dogs you're like
yes and you get out of like horses
you're like yes yeah then you get
something like rats you're like okay
yeah and then you start getting these
weird fish and you're like what though
like the deep sea fish yeah then you
start getting into the real [ __ ]
weird fish the ones like all like no
eyes and just old teeth
like what the [ __ ] is happening down
there it's like something it's like
creatures it is like legit like
the fit like what's going on with fish
[ __ ] like that yeah
like what who who's this is an episode
of science who's in charge what is up
with this who's in charge of the
evolution down there it's like out of
control you guys heard about the
immortal jellyfish no no
listening so there is there is a species
of jellyfish that scientists believe are
like immortal like they cannot they
cannot be
killed by like time by old age so
obviously they can still be killed by
external forces
or whatever but that's brilliant but
it's believed by scientists that they
are
in a sense immortal and that scares the
[ __ ] out of me that's just because
nothing should be immortal nothing alive
should be immortal that's just the
survivor stand from past seasons yeah
they just have like nowhere yeah that is
literally just a stand right
you can't die apparently they reckon
that aging is uh like a process like
cells and stuff yeah it's on purpose
yeah i'm not bullshitting right actually
that there is something called the
immortal jellyfish yeah apparently it
just regresses into like a pollen form
and then it comes back again oh yeah so
it's literally just like a single cell
like organism kind of deal where it's
like it's just forever just like
re-creating itself basically yeah yeah
so a car accident just turned back into
a baby and grew back again that's a
benjamin button
that's actually just a [ __ ]
superpower that's pretty that's [ __ ]
cool dude yeah yeah but could you
imagine though if like humans were able
to somehow like study that [ __ ] enough
right and be like we're trying i think
yeah yeah and you know being like all
right this might actually be like the
key to immortality what's the point of
being immortal if you get to 60 and
you're like you're useless at 60 and
you're like what are you gonna do for
another hundred years well that's why
they can regress in age as well because
they're just like
they're gonna get to like a point where
they're like [ __ ] i can't like i can't
do sports anymore time to go back
let's just say we can like keep you
alive right till 200 but like after 50
you start like you know you start
degrading and then 70 you're kind of
useless yeah yeah well you're just going
to say i'm not saying all people are
useless by the way but like like you
personally can't do what you want right
that is the point of you being like
another 130 years another 100 years like
what are you gonna do like just like
catch up with like the rest of game of
thrones yeah that's why like that's why
like i remember uh [ __ ] you know like
in futurama episodes yeah you know when
they have all those like old celebrities
from centuries ago just as heads yeah
yeah yeah i remember one of my friends
was like oh man wouldn't it be cool if
we like humanity got to that point in
technology i'm like no what are you what
do you want that would be horrible
you'd just be sitting on a shelf for the
rest of humanity like the rest of yeah
time rest of time rest of time just just
doing what how do you like
how do you how do you have fun
you're just a head in a [ __ ] jar
i don't know perfect beat boxing or
something like yeah that's that's all
you can do
as a head just like
that trick right with the cherry stem
where you can tie it out
what else you're going to do
well there's perfecto jojo
learn languages i guess for the rest of
time in every language in the world yeah
probably or just or just so now i think
about there is a few things you can do
just watch pokemon in your mind yeah
exactly the ultimate life hack
oh what are you doing i'm just watching
the 6 000th of rerun of pokemon yeah i
mean like i mean like i i guess it's
like a really philosophical question of
if you could be immortal would you want
to be immortal and i'm just like
i i wouldn't want to be a muscle maybe i
wouldn't want to die at like say 80 or
90 or whatever but like there's a point
where i would like my body to keep up
with what i want to do right okay well
then different question
how old if you could choose how old
would you want to be when you die
what to me it depends on how functional
i am yeah right because like i yeah i've
i've met 90 years old 90 year olds who
are like still in like [ __ ] tip-top
shape yeah yeah yeah um and i've also
met you know like 60-year-olds who have
trouble doing things that i would want
to do as well 50s yeah yeah yeah yeah it
depends on how unlucky you get really
yeah yeah yeah you know some of my
friends you know that that some of their
dads like 55 already getting like
dementia and stuff yeah [ __ ] yeah i
would hate to get that especially if
like my kids are young like i don't want
them to feel like yeah they've got to
help me out yeah i think i think the
coolest answer was uh like my grandad
um
apparently like in his twenties he was
like from from his twenties he was like
i'm gonna die at age 80. just like
just no cap i'm gonna die at age 80.
yeah and for the longest time i was like
why why would you say that from a young
age and he's like because it gives me a
time limit to do all the things i want
to do before i die right and so it's
like self-motivating and and this is how
much of a chad my granddad was he died
exactly at age 80. and he was literally
he was he was literally like i'm i'm
good man i'm good to go i'll ask how he
dies from lung cancer but
i was gonna say i'm like the dish man
how did that go down i mean the thing is
i think it sounds like he did everything
yeah he was literally like on his 80th
birthday he was like i can go now with
like no regrets just like waiting for
the clock to turn
yeah it's like it's like ready to pour
we're gonna pull the plug
but like i thought i thought that was so
[ __ ] cool right because like there's
that like very common philosophy of like
you know if you became immortal you
would do nothing because you'd have no
like rush you'd have to drive
because you can do it whenever you want
so yeah i mean that's my reasoning for
why i wouldn't want to be a model also
like i don't know i don't want to see
everyone around me die
that should be so funny i mean like if
you live in a society where everyone can
choose how you know when oh so okay so
if we were living in an immortal society
yeah yeah society
if we lived in the society
then i think we'd just like regress to
the [ __ ] stone age at that point
because like no one would want to do
anything yeah yeah yeah i mean like for
me like
personally
i find like the most badass people are
the people who like live till like the
late they're late ages and they like
they seem fit they seem able and then
one day they just decide to like their
body just decides all right peace out
yeah you know that's the way i would
want to go you know i don't want like
that i think everyone wants to go like
that yeah but like life is brutal it is
i like uh i think it's like the
tezukosama the the guy who basically
popularized manga he died while drawing
manga in the hospital then and i'm like
that's so [ __ ] badass the fact that
like this man literally till the moment
he died was doing what he wanted to do
yeah god's gonna be doing that final ten
pull
he gets 10 ssrs and he's like
connor's going to be on like jump king
20.
on the phone the final jump
no but yeah because like my my like uh
my grandma right now is uh
is still alive and like she's in like
her late 90s right now and i remember
when i introduced her to sydney for the
first time
uh and i remember i was telling sydney
oh you know she's she's in the 90s you
know i think you've definitely told this
story have i told his story i think you
have okay
okay so yeah uh my grandma like squeezed
took sydney's hand and squeezed it she
squeezed it so hard that sydney was like
writhing in pain for like a good hour
because of how hard she squeezed it um
and yeah that was that was a cliff notes
for the story because i think maybe i
have told this on trash too so basically
your grandma's giga chat yeah yeah have
you ever heard the story i think so yeah
yeah i think they seem familiar i can't
i can't see sometimes you can't tell if
you told if i've told you this at a bar
or something on the podcast
unfortunately we talk
a lot unfortunately we do talk a lot i
wrote i saw a recent comment on one of
the trash today's episodes being like
it's so impressive how the boys still
manage to find topics that they've never
taught i don't even know like yeah i
don't even know i just talk and like
sometimes we get called out for it
sometimes we don't i don't know
it's whatever yeah definitely spoke
about [ __ ] up fish in the ocean i know
that have we no we haven't oh we haven't
no i haven't there's so many [ __ ] up
little fishes the animal that scares you
the most men no chewing um
[Laughter]
martians martians
i think
i think you know like those t lists of
like animals that i could take in a
fight yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't know why i just think like a a
deer would just [ __ ] me up i mean they
could yeah like more i think i'd have
more chance of like being able to outwit
a bear or something
or like being oh
has taught me anything don't [ __ ] with
bears which are the ones with like the
massive antlers is it dears are they all
dears i mean
i don't know no maybe not moose but like
there's some caribou i've i've seen some
of them that are [ __ ] insane i mean
moose are like [ __ ] like
insane yeah
like people imagine moose and they're
like oh yeah that's like just a big deer
right i'm like no they're [ __ ]
they're like huge
insanely huge it's scary even though i
think i there's like a 0.1 percent
chance that i could
live it with a bear encounter yeah
i at least think that like a deer i'd
have like zero if it wanted to kill me i
feel like it would just chase what
what what logic are you facing this time
what kind of thing
are you like
the way it looks at me i don't know why
you're talking you're talking about like
the deer from princess monarch okay
they got to look in their eyes
right they got a look in their eye that
says i'm up for blood and i'm i'm not
going to be talking about deer's the
cutest [ __ ] all the time i mean have
you never been to naro
we can feed the deers they're like no
there's like wimp tears like chad chad
diaz have you seen those deers when
they're wrestling each other for like
mating purposes oh yeah yeah dude
let's just say if one of these deers
thought i was gonna steal its gf
i'm done like it's i'm dead i think you
can say that about most animals though
like if you were like if you tried to
steal like uh yeah
if you want to go to a frat party i'm
sure you feel the same way as well right
oh this guy's gonna [ __ ] me up
i remember
there's like stories
what logic are you playing there's
absolutely zero logic
just the way it looks so are you saying
that like you can't take on a male deer
but you could take on say like a male
elephant
uh or a male giraffe what would we say
take on an elephant are we saying like
beating it well i mean you you were
saying like t list of animals i could
beat in the fight right right right
right right right right in the fight or
like survive yeah i i reckon i could get
away from a bear let's let's say yeah
let's say like you're a caveman and you
need to take on one of these animals to
like survive like
yeah okay i think i don't know why i
just feel like a deer could chase me to
the end of the earth
i feel like a bear my gift like most
animals no no no i bear will get bored
after a while you know
they'll get bored i feel like a deer
clearly never encountered a bear in his
life let's say i climb a 20-foot tree i
know bears can climb trees but i reckon
the deer somehow would just [ __ ] jump
up [ __ ] me up naruto style something i
don't know why i'm just scared of these
deers man these big deers that are
tigers lions do you have like girls
i'll take a tiger i'll [ __ ] it did you
have like a childhood trauma around the
deer
is this just the british in you talking
do you even have deers of course we have
deers in england
are you sure about that don't look at me
do we have deer no like big the big
deals with the antlers like what's the
difference what are the what are the
ones with like the horns that are like
not that like all kind of spiky are you
talking about caribous i don't know what
they're called
like the ones with like weird shapes i'm
talking about like bambi [ __ ] right
no no no the ones are no horns aren't
scary why would they be scary they have
no horns gun ones are scary
but they're but they are but they are
also deer they are also dude
if i get on the back of a rhino right
what's it gonna do fall on the ground
i'll just jump off it
what about like a ram
a ram i've i've i've been with a ram i
befriended the rams we were friends so
so so you you don't find rams scary no
no they're just they're just kind of
like little [ __ ] rams
they're just kind of like drama queens
you can you can you can you can talk to
them
you can tell you can't you can't really
talk with me
with the deer
yeah
this isn't what bring them like one
tablespoon it's just a deer right
those would [ __ ] you up this is the mail
impaled bro you'll be in the tree like
i mean i'm not not gonna get off the
tree i'm not not saying they won't [ __ ]
you up but i have regrets
i'd rather take on that than a [ __ ]
bear yeah as well because when you see
that you think it's cute right you think
oh it's cute and then it [ __ ] stabs
you right a bear you're not getting
anywhere near that you're cautious right
it's about the position no i'm not going
anywhere near a thing that has horns
like that but they taste good though so
i'd understand why
so if bears tasted good would you
maybe
this is one of those things where it's
just like it's gonna make me look stupid
this argument but it's just pure like
gut like this is no logic whatsoever
this is just my gut feeling so is is
dear like s t for you like s t is scary
s here will [ __ ] you up and you didn't
expect it
bear is 80 because i know it i know it's
gonna [ __ ] me up but also it might not
it might get bored it might just leave
me alone
but what were you getting this idea that
dears are so [ __ ] aggressive yeah
i've i've seen videos man
i've seen videos of bears being
aggressive
because some dumbass is provoking a deer
right like yeah of course they're gonna
get pissed off i don't know you know i
just think that uh bears are you know
friendly because my experience with most
deers like even ones like that is that
you go like [ __ ] in a few again this
is a 50 meter radius
i am not trying to make any sense this
is all just got no you're not now you're
not making sense i know i know it
doesn't i know this isn't making it why
are we trying to glean some sense out of
it but
like tigers are scary
but also you know the tiger king seemed
like he had a good hand of it so maybe
i mean it is like it is he slapped them
with his uh his stick and they let go of
him so if i just give him a little get
off
stop that
yeah that was the problem with like all
the prey that you see they
oh yeah there was like a story from like
um
that i think brian blesses you know
brian blessed he's a very famous british
guy
he he's this really famous british guy
who has like yes the most booming voice
like this right and apparently he was in
the arctic filming something and a polar
bear came up and i think he either
punched the polar bear in the face or he
screamed at the polar bear and it ran
away scared
this story so i'd like to think that i
could if it is true that you could scare
a polar bear from shouting at it i think
i'll be all right well i mean
bucky has taught me that like the best
way to beat a bear is to punch it in the
nose yeah i heard that you could punch
it in there but probably not the grizzly
bear probably just
yeah well i mean if you're fast enough
right
i mean not fascinating
i mean at that point you're lucky
at that point you're kind of playing
gacha with your life you know yeah
it's the same thing with sharks right if
you if you punch a shark in the nose
then it'll just be like that is that
true i don't know
i've tried it i wouldn't try it i mean
i'm not going to try it but you know
like nature's like world's slowest punch
underwater punch nature's literally
giving them a weak point
i punched the shark for massive touches
where you're gonna punch a deer huh you
can't punch it anyway it's got
big spiky things right i feel like i
feel like you could like you know
dodge at the last moment yeah you can
like devil back yeah
what are you talking about bears are
[ __ ] fast as [ __ ] when have you seen
a bear huh this is the most dumb
conversation we've ever had
you're so like if you see a bear like
like a grizzly bear you are not running
away from that no you can't now run a
bit yeah no but like the best tactic is
that you can outrun your mates maybe i
can maybe i can shout at it ask it
kindly to stop
you know it's like
okay let's have
why don't we ask survivors of bears
right what they did to survive the bear
uh i like to ask how many bear survivors
do you know there's got to be a few out
there
i'm pretty
there are sure yeah because no one talks
about it because everyone sometimes
deals because they know if they talk
then it's going to come back
is going to come back for something then
comes back with his family like
you should be smitten
it's like how many horror movies are
there with deers as like the main
monster that's because [ __ ] [ __ ]
people are too scared to talk about
dears
like the next like when's the next deer
coming out in the godzilla trilogy or
whatever man
king kong vs king kong and godzilla
versus deer they need to tag team the
ultimate monster do you man it can it
can go run super fast launch itself in
with those hooks you know you're done gg
so would you say the deer is the most
powerful animal
it's the most powerful
spiritually if it were to animal like
battle royale would you pick deer no
no who would you pick for an animal
battle royal animal kingdom battle royal
um
i'm definitely picking polar bear for
sure i feel like you're going for low
hanging fruit i feel like there's
probably something stronger yeah because
i'm trying to win yeah
i feel like there's probably better
animals maybe if you ask tls the tiazu
guy i'm sure boris
walrus
i don't think so okay okay the only
reason i say this is because i i
literally saw a video where like a polar
bear truck was like [ __ ] starving
hadn't eaten for a while uh so he was
trying to hunt and he comes across these
like this group of walruses i don't know
what the proper word is the herd
and like he literally tried to like try
to take a bite out of any walrus yeah
right and their hides were like so thick
that he that like they couldn't he
couldn't grab on and walls just like
shook him off and he tried with like
several walruses and like he just failed
so maybe maybe it's walruses that are at
the top of the [ __ ] food chain and we
just never thought about it
the honey badger that one's like a scary
one right
i would like a [ __ ] i think the polar
bear would destroy the honey badger i
don't know man
i mean human versus honey badger yeah
the honey badger is probably gonna win
yeah but like you know because i don't
want to [ __ ] with a honey badger
what is a honey badger it's a badger
that eats honey no it's not no it's not
no yes it is is it primarily honey i
thought it was like this yeah because
it's not like [ __ ] crazy isn't the
whole thing of it with a honey badger is
that like its height is so thick that
like a bee sting literally can't
penetrate it i don't know why they're
like that shit's crazy i i remember i
read something about it shrimp you know
mentorship i know [ __ ] manchester
united
yeah my god like that okay that that's
when nature is [ __ ] cool yeah see
fish it's always fish like what's going
on like manchester shrimp is like the
bucky of the scene why does this fish
have like a cannon for an arm like
what's going on with that
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna throw a
fist and create a sonic boom yeah what
happened with evolution
like i'm telling you man evolution in
the sea is [ __ ] like i don't know
what's going on when is the next state
like stage above that it's like oh i
throw a punch and a nuclear fusion
happens
black hole with my fist yeah i mean if
you use like sliced up a manta strip but
i think it could possibly like create a
[ __ ] vacuum that sucks sucks the area
and sucks his opponents in so that's
what bucky should have done instead of
imagining a human-sized uh praying
mantis he should have imagined a
human-sized manta strip
it's gonna be the one punch man yeah of
course why are we talking about this
again
the one punch man of the sea you know
you know what one uh thing that um i
always
there's like i think this is youtube
videos where like people like kind of uh
go to like nature and they like save the
animals that are like being hunted or
something yeah yeah by other animals
yeah okay right and then they ask like
david attenborough questions like do you
ever feel like you should uh help the
animal that's being hunted and stuff and
he's like no
it's literally nature why would i
[ __ ] interfere yeah like i i don't
understand why people always make these
videos being like today we're gonna save
the fish from being eaten it's like
that's literally the point of the fish
that's
literally called a food chain yeah yeah
yeah we just we're just sympathetic
because we're at the top
yes if we're if we're in the middle of
that if you're like
i'm trying to save my own life
yeah i don't think cavemen uh really
worried about uh what nature was doing
because we were we were trying our best
to survive as well that's like a seagull
being like i'm gonna save these fish
today
because i feel bad
like no they don't give a [ __ ] they're
gonna eat this episode is brought to you
by call of antier a beautiful and well
crafted casual gaming experience call
avanti is the perfect stress-relieving
game with fun and laid-back match 3 rpg
gameplay what better way to unwind than
to match those threes and to collect
yourself over 60 beautiful designed
heroes call avantia has a ton of rich
gameplay modes majestic scenes legendary
figures dragons castles and exciting
adventure oh my lord it even has online
battle modes and massive events which
you can participate in to win free items
and in addition to those you also get
free daily summons of legendary heroes
the free daily summon hero featured now
is morgan a dashing four-star legendary
pirate hero who can inflict scurvy on
her enemies by a touch of her sword so
download call of anthea today by using
the link in the description down below
or conveniently scan this qr code on
screen right now to download it but
gentlemen hold on because the first 300
users who use our promo code trash taste
will get a special reward package
including get this what what joe tell me
200 gems 200 gems 30 plus energy points
30 energy points and 30 000 gold oh
all of that to kick-start your profile
off in style thanks again to colavantia
for sponsoring this episode back to the
show when i go i guess i'll bring it up
now i just googled the most dangerous
animals in the world
um and obviously like you got
you got your normal ones like stone
fishes on there box jellyfish is on
there you know black mamba or australian
all the australian ones uh then you get
number two number two mosquito of course
that's oh yeah that does make sense
[ __ ] you're not number one
humans
we are we've like killed everything
we're awful
trust no one not even yourself
what's the what's the
strongest animal you genuinely
wholeheartedly think you could you could
be in the fight what it
define beat in a fight
like just a fist because like the
animals are going to be like oh there's
no like
yeah like like bring it bring into
submission
kind of thing like what are we talking
about i don't know like or like run away
like the amount of runs away or like
like or you're like not like it's like a
fight or a fight to the death yeah for
some reason you're in are we allow tools
no just your bare face just your bare
fist and whatever is laying around on
the ground all right i got it uh
realistically realistically dog human
why are you fighting a doctor
you were human or human yeah he's like
dog
patients
not that i would
no like like a bit like a bit like if
we're not counting humans like a big dog
is probably the max i can go because
even then like you know
it's [ __ ] scary a big dog would beat
you up actually
i mean a big dog i mean like some really
big yeah it could really [ __ ] hurt
could you take on a wolf
i mean it'll be hard but i feel like if
you're fighting for the final year of
the movie for sure yeah yeah yeah yeah i
feel like you could take on a wolf not
like
it's not a guaranteed win yeah that's
like on the edge of what i imagine if i
was fighting for my life is it like a
hundred percent like success rate no no
but like you know but like could i
possibly get a wolf into a [ __ ]
chokehold or something go [ __ ]
[ __ ] ufc on his ass then maybe maybe
if i had the right techniques
all i'm saying human wolf versus wolf in
the octagon i'm just like you know
learn some bjj you have some bjj maybe
like maybe you might have a more
fighting chance you know
you're dead
because i mean how how small do you
think a wolf is pretty big do you take
on a sheep maybe you're gonna beat up a
sheep
beat up a sheep i mean not that i would
want to i don't think this sheep would
even fight no
i think you should just be like just
take me
let's just take me away right now
what about you connor what about you
what what is the absolute max that you
you would think like okay i could
survive this catfish
a catfish
i don't even know i don't even know i
don't really think about it well yeah i
don't think about this either
um
[Music]
maybe a very you know there's some tiny
monkeys very small monkey very very
small monkey maybe yeah they'd probably
give me a good [ __ ] fight
oh yeah definitely it'd be three rounds
at least of course connor says
of
course the weaker genomes of some of the
weaker ones you know species of monkeys
could you take on a chimp [ __ ] nerve
chimps [ __ ] chip what's your murder yeah
okay why are birds so [ __ ] sassy
like what why why why are they so cool
like what do you mean by sassy they just
have attitude like like so many [ __ ]
i've seen like you fly i mean come on
i would be sassy too if i could watch an
[ __ ]
it's literally looking down yeah it's
like probably but it's like you know
like you like the birds of prey aren't
the sassy ones it's like the like the
domesticated the small the smaller the
birds like the parrots right yeah the
parrots yeah powers are [ __ ] sassy as
[ __ ] my [ __ ] god also they freak me
the [ __ ] out because their voices how
like how do they do such an accurate
like representation of like pretty much
every sound yeah our family used to own
a couple of like different species of
parrot um like a cockatiel and like
lorikeets and stuff like that and like
yeah yeah
something camera recommended yesterday
that was parent was key witness in
murder trial
as a woman is convicted of killing
husband
11 million views
what is the power it's just like she did
it
talkative parent finger a killer
you heard right
don't [ __ ] shoot your parents
found shot to death at his home
that's crazy
was also found
with a gunshot wound this parent was
like
oh my god they were both that's again
i mean that's pretty [ __ ] cool i mean
like yeah cause like my my parrot used
to
replicate like sounds that we would
teach him but he would also just like
pick up sounds through osmosis right
like i've told this story how much is
something no you haven't you haven't
told this oh okay okay so like we used
to own uh this like uh cockatiel which
is like do you know what a cockatiel is
yes yeah so it's like a sassy sassy
[ __ ] yeah yeah sassy
[ __ ] right but um yeah cause
they're parrots so like they replicate a
lot of things so like we taught it to uh
whistle the adam's family theme song
yeah right so like every like we'd wake
up in the morning and it'd just be you
know whistling the animals and things
like and everyone was like oh that's so
cute but then other times the sassiness
would [ __ ] pull through on this mofo
and he would uh replicate sounds that
confuse the [ __ ] out of us so he
perfected uh the sound of the microwave
not not just like he would replicate the
buttons like presses perfectly so be
like
but then like you know when it's like
finished and it goes like
it would replicate that perfectly so
many times where like oh i'd be in the
living room and i would hear that and i
would walk into the living uh into the
kitchen thinking that like someone was
there no one's there i'm like oh my god
it's a [ __ ] ghost and then i realize
it's my it's my [ __ ] sassy bird
and also like it would replicate like
the phone ringing and [ __ ] like that
they're really smart they're really
really smart and uh it would also
replicate uh my mom saying good morning
so it'd be like it'd just be
if i ever get another lorikeet i'm gonna
i'm gonna teach you to go yeah
just to see how well i could replicate
that
oh my god anyway i remember there's some
like youtube videos where people like
mix it badly and they put beeps in it
for some reason yeah and when i'm in the
other room and i like the videos playing
and i hear a beep i'm like what's
happening in my kitchen
i hate people who do use beeps really
loud beeps in their youtube videos yeah
shouldn't do it yeah
i don't know
i was gonna i was gonna i thought you
were gonna go a different direction with
that conversation because i was gonna
talk about uh bass boosted monsters inc
memes because
how are you going to [ __ ] transition
i want to hear how this happens because
you're talking about people putting
sounds in like youtube videos and stuff
like that and i'm just like yeah i get
it
like on a tangent i still think the
funniest thing uh one of the funniest
videos is just people who like
take the bass boosted monster zinc theme
you [ __ ] love it and throw it into
like someone's sleeping or something
like to me that is just pete comedy
i don't know i just wanted to bring it
bring back the monsters think bass
boosted memes
literally had nothing to do with the
conversation and i was playing your mind
is just thinking about bass music
monster thing
i was playing 5d chess trying to like
relate these two things you were playing
5d chess we were playing checkers right
here
not even the same game
anyway enough about animals what have
you guys been up to in the past week uh
i had i bought a pc and it didn't work
oh yeah i saw yeah twitter thread on
that that was pretty sad so what
happened with that
so i was building it live which was
more stressful than last time
i think last time because
we
we did it like three times rip gant who
went first joey went to sleep
i went first yeah
yeah so doing it live was really
annoying because i was actually reading
chat when i just shouldn't have read
chat yeah because chat kept saying yes
or no yeah like i'd be like is this the
right thing to do half says yes half
says no yeah
well it shouldn't you already know
you've built yeah yeah it needs to be
the pc master right yeah you've always
you've already built a pc live on camera
yeah i probably could have just done it
but i just kept getting confused and i
and then when i get confused i get
nervous because i'm live and i'm like
what if i do something wrong and then
everyone sees that i did it wrong
because people are laughing
so so i wasn't about the whole point of
that but i wasn't really worried when it
was my turn doing it live because i'd
already seen two people build it so it
was really easy all right
um yeah last time she'd been more
stressful because it was a speed run as
well yeah yeah and it was okay it was
yeah yeah i still [ __ ] some things up
all right the m.2 i had trouble with
again yeah
that m.2 man yeah
i i built this whole thing i spent five
hours doing it because i [ __ ] up and
was wasting a lot of time and doing a
bunch of other stuff and i was
preoccupied so i finally built it to
five hours and it didn't turn on damn
did you find out why oh yeah so it's
working now i have it so uh the next day
i i you know i gave up it was like 1am
and i tried to boot it and it wasn't
working and um
i'm so i i was like all right fine i'll
just uh i'll give it a go tomorrow i'll
have a you know i have a clear head i'll
try all the problems i basically took it
all apart and rebuilt it all again going
very carefully through it all and
the same error kept happening and i was
like
what
like i even took like the cpu out put it
all back in make sure i did all that
right right i just like could not figure
out what's happening cause it wouldn't
go to the boot screen it was just black
screen and everything everything was
whizzing and you know glowing and all
that oh my god damn it
so then uh i'm talking to gigabyte and
i'm like hey
what's happening why isn't it working
everything is working why what what what
is happening yeah and so essentially
because i got a new
uh new specification it was a
motherboard that is a ddr5 ram
motherboard right now to those who don't
know anything about pcs uh basically
every now and then they they upgrade it
and they're like hey why don't we just
change the connectivity to [ __ ] with
everyone and uh
it does make it faster as well but they
change the specifications you have to
buy specific things yeah now this ram
slot that was called ddr5 i was like oh
okay i'll go on amazon and buy ddr5 ram
well apparently that's not what you're
allowed to do with ddr5 because it's new
uh motherboards have a set list of
specific ddr5 right that works with it
so not all ram so previously i think
ddr4
like all ram basically worked with all
ddr4 i think yeah right i've never
mostly nearly all of it it was like yeah
you'd have to try real hard not to do it
so yeah so then i was like oh okay is
that the issue it must be so i ordered
this new ram plugged it in worked
perfectly right so i wasted like two
days i was like a whole extra day trying
to fix this thing for no reason
yeah that's the thing about building pcs
sucks
to me instead of building another one
yeah to me i feel like to me the hardest
to me the hardest part is actually
selecting the parts right because like
building a pc like we said you know it's
it's frustrating but you can like it's
you can get through it it's like lego i
used pc part picker as well did you
actually check for compatibility issues
yeah it's all good
so it's all good go ahead go ahead you
got debated
damn yeah i mean it's it's it's it's
things like that that scare me because i
remember the first pc i built um the
biggest thing that went wrong was that i
had bought a motherboard that was not
compatible with the cpu
um because i had bought a i bought like
an intel cpu so i was just like okay
this me being a pc building virgin i was
i got i bought the motherboard i saw it
was intel compatible yeah not knowing at
the time that there are different types
of cpus and different types of chips oh
that happened to me as well yeah i had
uh the motherboard as well the cooler
doesn't fit but i just kind of shoved it
in place and now it's working
that's scary
it's working it's working was was this
the first pc you built in japan or just
the first one ever
third
in japan oh okay yeah i've built four
pcs in my life how did you 20 mine
oh fan five
and you still somehow found a way to
[ __ ] it up
again i went to pc part picker yeah and
it said it was okay so i had faith in pc
part picker because in the previous four
times i've never had
uh an issue
but what happened was is that the cooler
they sent me was one that was a bit
older
so it didn't include the like the
um
adapter bracket to mount the cpu but
this thing had like sliders so i kind of
slid them in the middle which they would
they'd you could tell that things didn't
want to be and then i screwed it on
right it works it all feels good it'll
feel secure did you call chris
i didn't i didn't i could have done it
yeah
everyone's like called chris i'm like
what so he can tell me how his
mcdonald's tastes
can you talk about his mac yeah it's
pretty sure he did a live stream
yesterday and he was just eating
yeah
i saw that and i was like chris like
this is not what i normally eat for
breakfast and i was like what a lie
sorry chris yeah
speaking of breakfast um so like
as you guys as you guys know like i've
been on like a little bit of a diet
recently you know because i gained a lot
of weight when i went back to england
um i wouldn't exactly say recently
you've been on a diet for a while now
yeah because here's what happens right i
go on a diet for like a month have like
a week holiday either with the boys with
sydney pig out a bit gain on getting a
bit more weight so i'm still like i go
back to the diet after i'm back it's
it's like a healthy lifestyle i don't
think it's a diet i think you should eat
any help that's not a diet i mean i mean
i am eating healthy but i am definitely
taking in less calories than i it would
take to maintain weight so i'm not like
i'm not like this isn't a speed run but
it's like a it's it's like a slow
lose weight gain a little bit back it's
a slow run yeah yeah it's a slow run
it's a slow run um and yeah the reason
is uh when i went back to england
literally in [ __ ] september or
something
uh i gained a [ __ ] ton of weight because
i ate like [ __ ] and i drank every day
and i think like it was the first time
that i could physically feel my body had
gained weight so much that i remember
like i saw like a few comments of like
the before and after like trash taste
recordings after i came back trash
changed recording i think you can see
that i definitely i definitely did i
wouldn't say like overweight or anything
closer but you could definitely see i
did gain a little bit of weight so i've
been like working to
since that one holiday working to uh
working to lose that weight and now that
i'm taking in lower calories every day
i'm doing things that i wouldn't
normally do
like uh having breakfast
because normally i just normally what
are you a functioning member of society
i know right i know right i never eat
breakfast getting on his high horse i
eat breakfast yeah so because like you
know because i'm taking less calories
i've been getting hungry in the mornings
and so i'm like oh okay maybe maybe it's
time to start being a normal person uh
like everyone else in society and start
having breakfast like people like like
people like to talk about so have you
been enjoying it so yeah so because that
doesn't sound like you're enjoying it i
mean it's not so much i'm enjoying it so
much as i'm eating because my body
craves something inside my stomach
because uh that's usually what hungary
is yeah that is that is what hunger is i
don't get hungry at all when i wake up
no i mean either i i never used to until
i started having like salads and low
calorie meals every day and then i
started getting hungry in the morning
it's weird i only feel hungry in the
morning when i'm on a trip
yeah well when i'm at home i don't
actually know on a trip even on a trip
no really except if it's mcdonald's
breakfast
that that's the only breakfast i always
got time no one wants my vacation i'm
like four meals a day sounds about yeah
yeah i should eat yeah eat exactly
i wake up at like 7am in a hotel room
like why am i so hungry yeah that's not
normal yeah so like me and sydney have
been starting to eat like cereal and i
remember like as i've like added cereal
to my diet if you've been following my
twitter you'd know what i'm about to say
but i remember like having i remember
like eating the cereal one day and i'm
just like
oh no
i'm about to have a food take and
and
brace yourselves brace yourself
brace yourself i think i'm about to have
an opinion guys
um and i realized i think cereal is
better without milk oh god he said it
oh he said it and i'm i'm 50 50.
i like it with and without and i
remember i remember i remember just
eating one day and i just said it
casually to sydney uh and she looked at
me like i just murdered someone she just
dropped the spirit
she dropped the spoon in the milk
is that really that bad of a take
i mean apparently it is um
like you know weetabix in the uk as a
kid i usually just eat those dry
i think because i can understand that
because when you put that in milk it
just turns into wet cardboard yeah well
like i think it's better without milk i
i think that's i think that's what
anxious it's my mood you know some days
i want because you know it's a [ __ ]
challenge having to eat cereal without
milk it is it's like
yeah
it's it's like you're eating you're
eating scooby snacks like your dental
workout is insane but like i i hate it
when you pour the milk in okay and then
the timer starts because
just pour less milk i just put less than
i need how much milk are you putting in
i'm putting in the normal amount of milk
but it's clearly you're not you're not
yeah it's getting wet oh it's getting
soggy i hate soggy soup you should put a
little bit in and then mix it like force
it through the milk
but i also think that waters it down as
well you're having like cinnamon crunch
or something and then you i want the
cinnamon on the crunch i want the crunch
and the cinnamon together but like you
put the milk in i wouldn't put any more
milk water down wouldn't putting more
milk water in there no that's what
that's what i'm saying i don't want any
milk in there because i like the taste
of cereal as it is but if you just put a
little bit of milk just to wet it yeah
just a wedding
yeah it like brings out the flavor i
literally put like the bare minimum milk
if i do and then i just keep like
rinsing it through the milk yeah that's
exactly what i do so that by the time
you finish it you only have like a tiny
pool of milk do you think it tastes
better with the milk in it though yeah i
just because most of the time when it's
a no milk i'm like tired by the end of
it i'm
not that i really eat a lot of cereal
anymore but yeah every time i do feel
like a cereal like bottle i just yeah
it's it's milk
you know i just
is is cereal that good for you i just
feel like cereal is like you don't need
it that much well it depends on the
cereal yeah it depends on the cereal
like you know a bowl of fruit loops
isn't going to be like breakfast is
pretty good right i like bran flakes
yeah
but then i bought this bran flakes in
japan and it had like fruit in it and so
i was like oh okay that sounds nice it's
got dried fruit yeah i like that and
then i look at the back of the package
i'm like a normal serving contains 50
grams of sugar what
what
what are they putting in this this
i think i think that's why i stopped
eating cereal not just because like i
started to not get hungry in the
mornings i was like so bad for you but
yeah a lot of it is depending on the ceo
it depends on the cereal that you buy i
mean yeah i'm sure you know if you're
eating like a bowl of wheat wheat picks
right then like yeah obviously that's
got a lot of you know health benefits
but also i don't want to start my
morning with wet cardboard in my mouth
you know i just don't want to start a
morning like that i'm sorry maybe you
just hate wheat to mix jokes i do
i do i [ __ ] hate it i feel like maybe
there's just no saving like even like
with milk or without milk it just tastes
like [ __ ] to you i'm going to be
so non-australian when i say this i
[ __ ] hate weepics it's it's like and
you know people are like yeah just like
but you can just like add sugar or like
yogurt or like you know other things
into it i'm like well then that kind of
takes away from the health benefits give
me the yogurt just yeah just yeah i'll
just eat a top of yogurt that's fine see
like for me like cereal has always been
even even now as i see it i've always
felt that it feels like a snack right
because to me like to me people like
people have told me that they can't get
full
having cereal without milk and i'm just
like well to me it's like i'm not even
that hungry and breakfast you know to me
like cereal is just like a quick snack
before we get to lunch yeah that's your
chat in my in my lifetime i think i've
eaten more cereal past 1 a.m than i
actually have in the morning like it is
it is the most perfect midnight snack i
really don't like eating cereal in the
evenings well what about like late at
night like as i mean last night because
i've had it i always actually really
i wish i liked it because then i feel
like that opens a lot of possibilities
snacking options unfortunately i don't
know what you snack at midnight then
what's like your mid your go-to midnight
snack
i try and avoid it obviously at all
costs but crisps crisp stuff yeah but i
mean
what's wrong with that it's just the
most british thing you've ever said
i love christmas like i should have seen
this one coming up i was like i was like
like searching through the recesses of
my mind to think i know connor what
would he say and i'm like of course it
would be [ __ ] love chris you mean you
eat that as a meal though no sometimes
i've seen your tweets
i've seen you eat doritos as a meal
don't lie to me listen if there's no
other choice there's no other choice
i don't know man there's always a choice
that choices
i don't feel good about it but i do it
i do it why um they're good but like i
couldn't i i can't no matter how full i
get from eating just doritos yeah i
can't in my head i can't process that as
this is my meal yeah i i do it and it
doesn't feel like a meal but i'm just so
full that it's like this will last till
morning
i mean i'm sure i will
and then i'm in a lot of pain but it's
pretty good
i've been there don't worry i've been
like yeah yeah i get i just i'm not a
big cereal guy i
i don't even like did you eat it as a
kid because i can't remember because i
used to eat it a lot as a kid and i
don't remember the exact point that i
stopped eating cereal
i show up to toast when i was a kid yeah
after halfway through school i must have
decided that i prefer toast so i eat
four pieces of toast i think i had a
very brief period from cereal to toast
and then it just very quickly went from
toast to nothing but i feel like toast
and cereal in like the same category of
not very good nutritional value but it's
not the worst thing in the world yeah
like it's not bad but it's also not
great actually you know the moment i
actually know the moment i switched from
toast to no breakfast was when i started
having coffees in the morning yeah no
tea for me too yeah like just having a
piece of toast with a hot drink you
can't beat it not even that for me it
was just like just replace the toast
with a cup of coffee wait what wait wait
yeah what like from like like i mean i i
do that now yeah i do that now as well
but like from like i'd say for me maybe
like 17 18. i was just like yep coffee
that's it that's all i need i would eat
toast in japan but the bread sucks and
the other place you get good bread from
is like bakeries and they're stupidly
expensive yeah yeah it's like 50 bucks
for a slice of bread what what like irks
me about a lot about like the normal
japanese bread that they sell
supermarkets is just how [ __ ] thick
it is
it's ridiculous it's like insane it's
like that i'm like it could barely fit
in my [ __ ] toes
that's true i'm not gonna lie right i
know this is gonna make me sound
privileged as [ __ ] yeah i don't wanna
[ __ ] cut the bread
i wanna just chuck that [ __ ] in the
toaster i've just woken up right i don't
want to have to get the breadboard out
the bread knife out
oh it's too thick oh i've cut it badly i
just want the perfect slice this is not
a privileged thing this is just this is
absolutely a privileged thing what are
you on this is this is why they say the
best invention since sliced bread
yeah it's literally it's literally a
human revolution right don't you just
want to just do you really do do you
really slice bread really that
revolutionary i want that one like
i want to know why i've never thought
about actually the history of that
saying it literally it takes 10 seconds
dude but it's not it's not the act of
cutting it it's the cleaning up i have
to clean up a [ __ ] breadboard a bread
knife now just for like one slice of
bread like if i just have if i just have
the sliced bread i chucked that [ __ ]
what about if you just buy the loaf of
bread for example the uncut loaf of
bread on that day you slice it up
preemptively you put it back in the bag
and now you've got no you've got to do
that i did that no that's [ __ ] up i
mean i can't really really like speed
run it going bad no
yeah i don't think i've ever bought
breads that's not been pre-sliced now
that i think about it in my life see at
least wow privilege right now
you call me privilege for slashing my
bread at least i've done the leg work
i've been there i've been in the
trenches sliced my own bread
i've lived that life i've lived a lot on
that now
like aside from like you know [ __ ]
baguettes or whatever yeah i've i've
never actually sliced my own like wow
loaf of bread
yeah call me privilege call me favorites
upper classes right here this is like
the the like the opposite of like you
know people from england have never
cooked like their own rice or something
you know me an asian i've never sliced
my own bread before
there is a bakery near me that i really
like yeah
the loaf of bread is uh
six bucks i think how being half half a
standard size
yeah yeah okay half a standard size i'm
sure it's great i'm sure it's great i
just don't want to pay six bucks for
half half my life i've had yeah because
like mine i have to cut it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me yeah like for six
bucks i'm not [ __ ] cutting that yeah
that's ridiculous i mean
i thought that as well but then at my
previous place we lived right next to
like this like really high-end bakery
and like a full loaf like like this big
was like nine bucks or something which
is like [ __ ] audacious still still
expensive but then and i thought it was
just like a scam being like oh jack just
this is just japanese
yeah this is just japanese people not
knowing good bread but then when i
bought it and i had it and you know i
had to slice it myself god forbid i had
to slice it myself and uh yeah i made
toast with it i'm like okay
i can see why this is nine bucks no no
it was amazing it was very good but it
was not no no i wouldn't pay nine bucks
for that outside of japan is what i'm
saying
why why would you pay for inside japan
because every other [ __ ] brand of
japan sucks
and it's like look don't get me wrong
i'm not [ __ ] buying this every day
for me this is like this loaf of bread i
would this nine dollar life of bread i
would buy was like maybe like once every
like couple of months how good was that
like in terms of
bread in general this nine this nine
dollar bread compared to like it was
[ __ ] good like it was better than
like any like supermarket bread i would
buy in like australia or like anywhere
outside of japan so it was like i've had
the same bread because i bought it it
was it was good it was really really
good like i was like okay this actually
tastes like
how does it compare to like say the
bread in europe you know i think the
bread that i had in france and germany
was better well yeah oh no obviously
i'm asking how much better was it than
this top-tier bread top-tier nine-dollar
bread that we have brought in like
marginally it got to that taste where it
was good like it was very good yeah
right but then that the one in germany
or france will cost like
one euro fifty yeah obviously yeah it's
not i mean you know opposite opposite
opposite with rice right if you're
having rice in europe then obviously the
one in japan is going to taste better
just because you know in the uk it was
like what were pound for warburtons is
it warburton's the toast bread i love
that yeah it is very good bread
although i would not and even in the uk
right when you buy animals when you buy
the loaf bread at the supermarket the
one that isn't cut yeah you can be like
can you can you can you cut it for me
you can buy uncut bread at the
supermarket yeah we have baker we have
bakeries in the you know we have
bakeries in the supermarket do you know
what a bakery is there's a bakery right
and then when you get your your pastries
wherever they all sell loaves of bread
yeah
pastries i've never seen a loaf of bread
yeah they have it and if you want the
loaf of bread uncut you can who does
that who asks for that a lot of people
do because a lot of people like you know
if they're making their own stuff then
it's not not a big deal that they're
cutting because they want it because the
moment you cut it the time is ticking
it's already going bad right yeah that's
why you don't want to cut the whole
bread then put it back in because then
those slices that might have tasted a
bit fresher 2-3 days are gonna be
rock-solid did you never put like your
bread in the freezer
what no because that's the way to make
bread long-lasting that's what we're
used to in australia i'm sure a
yeah it's to preserve exactly it's the
british it's 20 000 degrees it's to make
the bread last longer that's like
putting ice in beer you know like like
that's the the
[ __ ] you just don't do and like you
gotta understand like the loaf of bread
in the uk and in europe it's bought on
the day intended to all be used on that
day oh okay it's not supposed to be
obviously you can have it a day yeah
that's not a big deal but but we don't
you know freeze the bed because because
they're strange because the australian
lives are bred there's like 20 [ __ ]
slices right so even a family can't go
through it in like a day how big is this
bread like this just buy a smaller like
plus a loaf of bread like this yeah it's
like it's like regular like this big or
like 20 slices in it so obviously
yeah does it taste as good i want an
image of this
exactly i need an image of australian
bread no yeah so what you i don't
believe that it's like the bigfoot of
bread this can't be real yeah so like
you know just to make the bread last a
little bit longer because you don't want
to have [ __ ] loafs of bread every day
right especially if you're living in
like my household which was kind of half
rice half bread
right um
like this yeah i'm not even the bread
guys like the size of the uk one but
yeah
but they're way thinner older
yeah but like anyway so like yeah to
make the bread last longer uh we'd put
you know we would use the slices we
needed to use on the day we buy it and
then we immediately go into the freezer
because it'll last like an extra two or
three weeks and then you just and if you
want it if you want a slice of bread you
grab it you know obviously it's frozen
because it's been in the freezer if you
throw it into the toaster
instantly defrosted tastes like i'm not
even the bread guy and i would never put
myself down to such savagery as [ __ ] as
pudding as putting uh bread in the
freezer i'm sorry you higher privileged
people could buy bread whenever you
wanted my family was saving money all
right
your family had a financial advisor joey
what are you talking about
and that financial advisor was like
freeze your brand you got to change some
things around here you want it you want
that you want that new apartment you
better freeze your goddamn bread boy
it's the asian mentality yeah yeah you
put everything to put everything in the
freezer last longer save money yeah
exactly no i think this is [ __ ] this
is just your excuses for living like
savages
yeah we're australian yeah
if it was something like oh we don't
want the spiders to get it okay well
that too no no because you would get a
bread bin yeah no because the bread bin
would be [ __ ] annihilated by the ants
what yeah
because we're in australia this you
can't escape from the wildlife
you leave the door open for one second
too long your house is [ __ ] overridden
by ants
the one thing that makes me not proud uh
to be thai is one thing that they do
and i just said it they they put ice in
their beer that's disgusting and like
it's
i mean i i see the logic because
obviously it's like 30 35 degree weather
beer's gonna get warm uh beer's gonna
get warm a lot faster but even me even
me i'm just like no no ice my beer
please no we're not we're not we're not
going to go is that like an option you
can get at any restaurant
um they normally was that like a
backyard thing no no by default okay by
default in thailand in a lot of like
restaurants
especially if it's open air right um you
order a beer they uh they take a cartel
they say they give you the beer and they
give you a glass and they put ice in it
and then they pour the beer in the glass
full of ice and you have to specifically
ask in a lot of places for them not to
do that right
um we're just trying to hide the [ __ ]
yeah is there anything worse than
watered down thai beer
what a nightmare i mean i mean you see
you do that with a chang beer and it's
just like this beer was already watered
down and uh you're watering it down even
more beer flavoured water
sorry sorry germans watching this yeah
the germans had a heart attack listening
to that like
but i've never i've never put bread in
the freezer i'll say that i'll say that
we've never put bread in the freezer hey
man
i'm not doing that i'm not saying you
should i was just saying that's what we
did and uh i know i thought it was
normal
is it is it like do you have to like put
like eggs in the fridge
yeah
i can't i can't i can't remember where i
heard it from where like if you have to
put like some things in the fridge or
some things are fine
and how it's cleaned right i believe in
some places in europe
uh they recommend you not to fridge the
eggs can you google this
if i recall correctly i think we didn't
keep our eggs in the fridge yes growing
up yeah don't think we did i don't think
we did either in japan you're supposed
to keep the
eggs in the fridge or i don't think yeah
you have to oh yeah you have to keep it
in the fridge european countries say you
do not yeah that's right that's right
really that's right i don't we had it in
a cupboard
really yeah well that's weird and in
america i think they put it in the
fridge i don't know about japan i don't
know as someone who's was just born of
like
just kind of you know every time i went
shopping with my mom and we'd buy a [ __ ]
the moment we should like open the front
door she'd be like eggs in the fridge
now quickly they're gonna go bad
apparently it's illegal to wash eggs in
europe so yeah like i've got like the
stuff illegal so you're putting the
fridge it's actually gonna grow back to
you what the egg police are gonna
[ __ ] rock up to my door be like um
i think it means for like transporting
it and stuff
yeah we don't yeah we kill them in the
cupboard i remember that yeah yeah like
bread you've never put in the fridge
eggs we've never put in the fridge
potatoes i don't think we've got that
potatoes were in the pantry yeah yeah
yeah
because i think if you put in the fridge
it grows sprouts right i don't know or
something like that i don't know i know
i know potatoes you're not supposed to
put in the fridge and onions yeah i
think cause i feel like rules different
with every different country i go to
because in thailand it's just like 90
percent of everything goes in the fridge
yeah because it's so much [ __ ] hotter
there yeah yeah it's hot it goes yeah
yeah hot and humid is like not the best
in
best temperature and conditions for
bacteria right so yeah yeah exactly well
like other things you shouldn't like
like chocolate you're not supposed to
put in the fridge i know i like putting
chocolate in the fridge wait why do you
why i think it's because like if you put
chocolate in the fridge then it turns
white and that just means that like it's
gone bad what i've never seen i like
chocolate in the fridge this sounds like
some [ __ ] i i love my chocolate it's
hot
into it yeah white stuff is not that the
chocolate it's just some other stuff
what what is that some other stuff i'm
worried
i don't know like i i i always heard
yeah i always heard you shouldn't put
chocolate in the fridge for too long
or like you could you can't let it like
sit in the fridge i don't know maybe
that's just me
it's either sugar or fat but it's not
the chocolate oh yeah okay yeah i
definitely prefer my chocolate in the
fridge okay there's there's two like
states of chocolate that are like my
favorite one is just like in the fridge
it's hard you get a nice nice crunchy
bite out of it and the second stage
where it's like like cheaper chocolate
it's like when it's perfectly room
temperature but not melted
if if like when you put in your mouth it
easily melts yeah yeah you put it in
your mouth and it doesn't like it
doesn't melt but it just like dissolves
in your mouth right that's like that's
like my second state of chocolate
because you don't like that no it's like
it gets all over your gums you're like
you don't even need to chew at that
point you just put it you just let it
melt and it just like disintegrates i
don't want it to do that's like a meat
when it's cold you can like chew into it
it like snaps apart and breaks into nice
chocolate bites i like that i don't like
it i don't like that too much because
i've had some instances where i'm like
what's going to break first the
chocolate or my teeth
i don't want to find yeah there are some
chocolates are like way too hard for
that yeah there are some like the
caramel bars i've never put in the
fridge oh my gosh it's hard if you put
hard caramel in the fridge like goodbye
it's just literally jawbreaking you're
just eating rocks at that point yeah
yeah what about ice cream do you like do
you like your ice cream like hard or
like soft serve do you like biting into
your eyes heart yeah like lollies like
like do you do you like ice cream though
okay yeah that's
i guess
that's an ice block your ice cream hard
or soft
well you've had like feasts right where
it's like it's like an ice cream one you
know if he's wears like a like a
chocolate in the middle and it's like an
ice cream around it oh you mean like uh
that's more of a
that's not so much ice cream though it's
more of like a ice cream bar i'd say
like it's more of a it's got like a
layer around it yeah because i know a
lot of people they cannot take like they
kind of cannot chew on like cold things
or like really cool things yeah yeah
at all i can't yeah can you not no i
[ __ ] i i love it too much where if
like i start chewing on ice yeah i
always hear you're like you'll be
talking to someone you're here like
just looking it's gone
it's gone it's gone god's not even
looking at you just staring off to the
distance like doing it crunching
i love crunching on ice
it's the best texture i love it i don't
know why i just it's
it's not good for my teeth at all i've
been told by my dentist and pretty much
everyone around me to like not do that
but like there will be times where i'm
like i i literally have to like
consciously not put ices in my drinks
now because i do it so much that
everyone's advised me to not do it is
that the real reason why you don't put
ice in your beer
i don't wanna chill on this ice man [ __ ]
the beer have you been in a social
situation or you like drinking your
drink and then you're like all right i'm
gonna i'm gonna
take this ice i'm gonna put it in my
mouth yeah but the cube's a little too
big
and your mouth's really cold but it's in
your mouth right and it's in there it's
in one of your cheeks if your thing is
freezing
you have that moment where you're like
if i i'm you're talking to someone you
don't look like a weirdo you're like
yeah if i bite into this it's gonna look
weird but if i swallow this i might
choke and look weird so what do i do i
need to reply in 10 seconds and they
stop speaking do i spit the ice back in
the drink and look like a [ __ ] weirdo
because if i if i go
so you were safe
have you been in that situation yeah
many times and i'm like i'm like my
go-to option is normally like just pray
that you can swallow this without dying
just pray really yeah my my option is to
just start crunching on that [ __ ]
i mean that's the least weird one yeah
that is the least weird one i've never
had an issue because i'm like constantly
crunching anyway i can't crunch it i'm
always definitely worried that they're
just going to think i'm a [ __ ] weirdo
when i spit it back in but yeah yeah
because if you spit it back in they'll
be like what the [ __ ] yeah spitting it
yeah spitting it back in
is the worst but my teeth can't bite
into it but i also don't want to be that
guy who's like
yeah so i've been in a situation before
keep throwing an idea where i'm like all
right boys here we go this might be it i
might be dead how many ice cubes have
you swallowed in your life like
uncountable uncountable over 10.
yeah that's a lot like normally i would
just try and like
come up with a pb would kind of
kind of try and move it around to get it
to a swallowable size all right right
as fast as you can or maybe just get it
so that it doesn't have harsh edges
wait you've swallowed ice cubes with
hard edges yeah like where they're like
full cue
no [ __ ] way no [ __ ] way yeah i i
would not i would be so terrified
normally the technique but the problem
is that this is where the technique
fails is that i'm normally doing this
after i've drank it so now i can't use
water to assist it flowing when i
swallow right so i have to swallow a dry
ice cube yeah i was saying that like
like you just like take a swig of water
or something that will like you know
that would like help melt it a bit
i just swallow it and uh yeah one time i
think i had a really big scare one time
because it got stuck
but i remember i had to play it cool
yeah because i was like i don't want to
make them do a heimlich maneuver on me
so i would just kind of keep like
keep trying to swallow it before i take
a breath and then eventually it went
down and oh my god my esophagus was in
so much [ __ ] pain yeah and by the way
never risk your life for a bit of social
uh awkwardness just i should have just
spat it out but yeah it was it was
terrifying just chewing it like a like i
could feel it because it was so big i
could feel it going down
and then getting stuck a little bit
sometimes yeah and then waiting and then
obviously it was because obviously my
body's really warm yeah so it would
slowly like dissolve you just gave your
esophagus like freeze burn what's
[ __ ] hurt
so much yeah no [ __ ]
don't do that
uh the lengths that a british person
will go to not be awkward in their
social circle just spit it out at that
point just
just spit it out you know what
i was playing like the most
important you know you know i will say
if i didn't love chewing on ice so much
i would probably do the same thing
i would rather
potentially risk having a choking uh
incident as opposed to having 10 seconds
of social awkward interaction yeah
that's why really yeah yeah that's the
british in me we just can't we can't do
it i don't know man like just like yeah
it's gonna be like yeah it's going to be
[ __ ] weird you know like speeding
your ice
drink or whatever but like it's like
i don't know how many situations can you
think of where you've saved in to dinner
with some other person right what's the
first date right first date with someone
yeah first day for example right if
you're on the first date with someone
right how many times have you gone to a
restaurant with say another a lady right
and she's gone
anyway yeah and then that at that point
your head's like no
wait wait i thought it would probably be
like
when is winning spitting ice back in
your glass the game changer i'm not
gonna lie it's one of probably the least
attractive things you can do it looks
very unattractive don't you think so
someone just
i think so
no no no no i think something that's
less attractive is you choking on an
iceberg
i've actually been in the situation
before actually not like
and i haven't swallowed it i've just i
just remembered right on a date you want
they want to know that you swallow
your will
oh my god
they didn't even notice it they didn't
even know that you just swallowed an ice
cream
my chest is like
no it's it's it's the tissue technique
right it's the tissue technique no no
it's not for a big ice cube they're
going to see your tissue on the table
you don't put it back on the table you
go for the tissue you pretend you're
just wiping your mouth or whatever
you're just like just
you've got to be subtle
because now they're going to think oh
this guy just choked out a massive
loogie in front of me this is this ice
cream
this this ice cube
when you when you like exude another
exude when you take out an ice cube out
of your mouth you don't go
no no no god this was this was like a
maybe a what the how big of the ice cube
we saw this is like a four four
centimeter cubed a four
four by four by four by four centimeters
let's say let's say that's a big [ __ ]
ice cube dude yeah that's what i'm
talking about okay okay no no if it's
that size i never take the risk of like
putting it in my mouth yeah i'm not
putting in my mouth i was dumb i don't
know why i did it because like at that
point right at that point um you
probably would have hardly even drank
your drink right because huh i'm the
speed let's see
it's like gone like it's let's say it's
a banging cocktail yeah like it's an
absolute winner yeah i love the cocktail
so much or maybe you know uh
i i'm like i want to order a bunch more
i want to try for more so i drink it all
and the ice cubes are still fully formed
because like at that point like the ice
cube just doesn't feel nice like like
like if you can feel the edges on the
ice cube it doesn't it doesn't feel nice
in your mouth i thought i thought when
you say when you swallow ice cubes i
thought you were talking about like you
know when you buy like a drink like
mcdonald's or something
are you swallowing whiskey rocks no no
it was like a i can't watch what i was
like you're literally swallowing like
whiskey like it was like a full-on
formed ice cube like it was a nice ice
cube that's why i wanted to put it in my
mouth
because
i was i i remember i was like yeah
i was like
i was like 19. i was you know thinking i
was fancy it probably i don't know what
i remember the exact scenario i remember
this specific scenario the reason why i
was so
committed to potentially dying to avoid
social awkwardness it was because
uh it was a first date and i was very
nervous and she was very attractive okay
i really wanted this to go well and so
you were like i'm gonna eat this ice
cube
and so for some reason
i think the 19 year old like was tapping
into like the fit 15 12 year old to me
that was like
that ice cube looks real good
because you know sometimes you see an
ice cube and you just put it in your
mouth because you're because you're dumb
and you're a kid and you you want to of
course i now would i know i have no
desire it really depends okay it really
depends as someone who has eaten a lot
of [ __ ] ice cubes in my life
as as the ice cube connoisseur here like
there's so many different factors right
because sometimes sometimes it's big but
like for some reason it's like hollow
inside right so you can take a good you
could shut it off sometimes it's just
like completely solid it's just like a
solid block of solid block of ice and
there is no
like there is no biting down on that
unless it's at least a little bit melted
yeah that's all and at that point it's
going to take at least like one or two
minutes irregardless of the size which
is
[Applause]
all right switch to space to grinding
technique
i remember it was quite a hefty boy it
was it was a weighty boy hence why again
i wanted to put it in my mouth
[Laughter]
it looks like i want all the trash they
said it's taken out of context it looked
too good not to like to allow it to go
away so i had of course yeah so for me
it's the opposite for me if it's like
perfectly the edges are like perfectly
rounded that's that's that's the that's
peak ice that's peak ice to put in your
mouth that is peak ice to put in your
mouth because it all you know you're on
the throttle
like the giant balls
no joke every time i get like
recommended a video of like one of the
waiters like shaving ice yeah it's what
it's like the most satisfying yeah in my
life whole yeah i need to say i don't
want to put it in my mouth um because i
don't want to die
oh yeah i yeah i've learned my lesson
with that it was also like clear ice
superior ice superiorized to like the
[ __ ] frosted ice that you get where
it's like clear outside and frosted in
the middle that's that's trashed here
right now
this is just like level one bartending
right yeah
no i mean just like i think
to chew on it as well
yeah sorry i'm just this this is like my
[ __ ] five-year-old this is live now
this is like my favorite crayons taste
like level of conversation it's like i
like the the maroon one
i like cherry red because it's got the
word cherry
do you prefer do you prefer
cube dice or how do you feel about uh i
don't give a [ __ ] no no no because
because i know a lot of people who
[ __ ] hate crushed ice oh yeah okay
actually yeah i do hate crushes i really
like crush i like crushed eyes yeah why
did you it's like a slushie
you get like okay so you everyone knows
my soda take right where i i like it
just the wrong one yeah i just i like it
where you know you take a little bit of
the fizz out and like to me like crushed
ice has more of a surface area to just
to just like to just like make soda like
the perfect the perfect texture and the
perfect flavor because if you drink it
without a straw
right yeah well it's it's great because
if you drink it with without a straw
then you get a lot of crushed ice that
you can chew on it
it's perfect you get the best of both
worlds this is like this is like you're
like yeah i don't mind they bring extra
extra colors in the crown package
to eat yeah yeah this is i i don't i
don't want to
taste the ice [ __ ] slush in my mouth
i want to taste the drink being cold
this is why when we go to denny's in
japan i hate their [ __ ] ice machines
what's the nice is always the the shitty
the shittiest like shaved ice yeah and
you drink it and you just get a mouthful
of shaved ice and you got to do that
technique where you're like
putting it in my mouth oh my god
i like it when it's like at the bottom
of the glass and then you do this and
then just oh my god
uh i mean you gotta like drink it you
know you go i mean it depends because
have you you've hung out with me so
you've seen how much you've done
i've seen how much shaved ice i put into
there minimum yeah the minimum amount of
shaved ice i put into a cup if i have
the choice is half the cup yeah that's
the minimum for me this is why when gang
goes to the movie theater he's like wow
look how much value i'm getting i get
i'm drawing four drinks today it's like
no god you've drank two this is filled
with advice this man buys chips and goes
to me like to me the saddest sight i've
i've ever seen in my life right is when
you go to like a shaved ice machine and
people put like a bit in like like like
a tiny bit like five percent of the
[ __ ] cup i do like one percent
and then most of the time
and then you yeah and then you fill up
with the soda right i'd rather people
put no in because you fill up this with
a soda the saddest [ __ ] sight it's
just seeing like one or two bits of ice
just like floating around in the soda
like that that's doing nothing it's
literally doing nothing why would you
put ice in if it's if that's all you're
actually gonna put in
i'm not living in a cap i've never given
a [ __ ]
i've never been like seething rage me
like god damn it because you can't even
chew on the ice that's that's why that's
why it doesn't matter it's gonna
probably get a [ __ ] melt
i'm gonna predict god's next take he
thinks that soup should be exclusively
eaten with straws
right no i don't i don't i mean it's
just yeah it's just a drink isn't it
yeah he's like oh it's a drink it's soup
less messy
and curry is a drink i want clown taking
you to come out with next guys
i'm i'm collecting them right now just
just give me more food taste the
infinity stones of [ __ ] taste
christ [ __ ] taste can be whatever i want
them to be
i think it's only a southeast asian
thing right where uh you can
you buy a soda at like a stand or
something right i don't know if i've
told this story before but you buy a
soda at a stand or something and then
they will serve it to you in a plastic
bag yeah is that southeastern is that
such
yes yes
[Laughter]
can they not afford plastic containers
or is this like an artistic choice
i don't know why it is right but i
remember the first time like that's as
weird as bag i remember the first time
because i remember i thought this was a
normal thing right because when i was a
kid i'd go to like a thailand every year
and on an especially hot day you'd you'd
go to a stand you'd order a soft drink
and what happens is uh they will have a
glass bottle and then they will yeah
like like that like that like that
so what happens is they they will have a
glass bottle or whatever soda you order
they'll uncap it and then they'll take a
plastic bag out just like put in that
[ __ ] ton of ice in the bag and just pour
the soda into the bag and give it to you
it doesn't sound that bad actually
that's actually kind of cool like a
comically large straw yeah they just
give you a straw
they give you like a twirly straw
so like what happens like let's say
you're like well [ __ ] you know this is a
lot of soda like how much you're talking
is it like a normal can 230 mil yeah
yeah yeah like a normal let's say you're
halfway through the can you're like oh
sheesh i wanna just put it down for a
second you can't put it down
hold on let me hang out my dreams
like how do i put it yeah so a lot of
restaurants will have these little
little hangers on like on like the table
or something that's actually kind of
cool
yeah that's true i completely forgot
about that they got they got the hooks
as well okay question then questions
because we were talking about chewing on
ice yeah how the [ __ ] do you chew the
ice from a plastic oh he shovels it with
his hands you just like grab it with
your hand
because you can't like you can't [ __ ]
do this right so when you're after
you've done drinking so you take the
plastic you can actually just take one
by one and just like
and they're like yeah
or you take you or you take the straw
and you just like you scoop a little bit
up
these like brand new plastic bags or
these like reuse from the guys
shopping you can be combined like you
don't know like grocery
can be oh should you get the aldi bag
bro i'm using lidl bro
i've never really thought about that
until yeah i want to know like how clean
this is yeah yeah i'd be very concerned
if he just whips out like some crushed
one from somewhere i'm like
a part of southeast asian culture that
we don't normally talk about i realized
it's a it's a good drink yeah it's it's
it's got i i like surely i i know this
is complete nostalgia talking but i like
the way though oh yeah the amount of
plastic in a bag is enough to make like
one cup right
no
what do you mean like surely you can
make a cup from one bag it's like
thinner it's like thinner right yeah but
plastic bags are quite what else now
what i want to know is why do they not
just give you the bottle
yeah why not you on the ice why do they
have to grab the bottle and empty it
into a bag why can't they just give you
the bottle i believe because they just
recycle the bottles
oh okay they send them back off i
believe that's that's what's happening
that's you can get a lot of drinks in
south asia they're kind of like a tub so
they yeah they scoop it out but surely
like the plastic
the plastic used on all those plastic
bags you could just convert into one cup
there's a lot of plastic in one plastic
bag yeah as the turtles well-known yeah
oh no like like i don't think i think i
don't think a lot of southeast asian
countries at the moment uh have much
awareness about plastic and trying to
reduce the amount of plastic i i
remember
uh i remember i'm just genuinely curious
like yeah yeah why it was i decided i
just genuinely think that that's just
like how it's been like some dude was
just one day i was just like
what if we put it down
i don't know where the plastic bag is
that should be hilarious
i could be showing my ignorance with
that but i'm just like surely there's a
better way
i'm sure there is
with our cups and stuff we line
starbucks cups like waxing maybe they're
just i don't know maybe they just don't
give a [ __ ] it's just like i just want i
just want my drink i don't care what
it's in i guess i mean i would be like
[ __ ] well well maybe you know maybe they
they are thinking in a recycling manner
where like after they finish the drink
they'll be like all right off to the
supermarket just like what fold it
inside out yeah yeah
all right brand new there we go i put my
groceries so like all right so you have
a car right yeah the cup holders was
useless
or just like we don't use okay so yeah
you're just hanging it up on like you
know the uh what's what's the thing that
you uh bro god forbid you you get a bump
in that car you go this is coke
you just go over like a patchy
and you're going up the mountain road
it's like
oh jesus christ well now what's the
worst is like what if you're you know
just walking along and then you happen
to like nick onto something and then the
there's a tear in the back
and you're in your pockets you're
spilling it yeah then you're just [ __ ]
you've got a shotgun that that has
happened before you just
i think we got it right a few thousand
years ago
i think we got it right yeah yeah
cops were invented for a reason i think
the
cup was pretty damn good you know i
don't want to sound like an [ __ ] i'm
not trying to like be like your culture
i'm not saying it's the next best thing
off the sliced bread or anything but
like it's you know it's pretty good
pretty sure the cup came before the
wheel like that was we had a really good
right there
nice the cylindrical uh the
cylindrical can right that was the best
invention right i've see i've seen that
youtube video i think everyone's saying
yeah i've seen that
30 million views
that's a pretty neat invention actually
it's uh the pressure is designed yeah
okay
we get it you watch youtube yes
speaking of youtube um
speaking of youtube youtube i've been
watching a few more youtube shorts
recently even though like like i know
like every time i go on like a youtube
shorts binge
it's like it's like bad for my health
you know like yeah there's it's to me
watching youtube shorts or watching tick
tocks is the equivalent
of
eating mcdonald's or eating fast food
right like i know i shouldn't do it but
sometimes sometimes just lying in bed
and you just scroll through and you're
like you just want that quick meal
and you're like [ __ ] 30 minutes have
passed and i've like consumed nothing uh
so like i've fallen down to like i felt
i fell down into this hole of like you
know life advice youtube or like life
hacks
right yeah and it's just like
like remember before where we went
through that life hack phase of like
buzzfeed videos where like the hack
isn't actually a hack so i thought that
died out but apparently that just went
to [ __ ] tick tock yeah right because
like i
i remember i saw i saw like a few
like career hacks of things you can do
in like to help you increase your
chances of getting a job interview right
and there's this i think i saw that
there's this tick tock of like that this
is how this hour goes the job
interviewer offers you a glass of water
the same thing yesterday
the white guy right yeah
yeah so the job interviewer offers you a
glass of water and then you take the
water and that's the hack because the
hack is if you take the glass of water
when it's offered to you they ask you a
difficult question and you just go
well you see the thing is and then and
the hack was because you have a glass of
water it gives you more time to think
about the answer and that was the hack
and i was just like losing my mind
that you could call this career advice
or a [ __ ] thousand likes and i'm like
this feels like
like the only time i ever see people
take a sip of water right for answering
the question is it like the criminal
trial yeah like when mark zuckerberg was
being
uh questioned by the senate yeah every
single question
yeah he was using a life hack dude he
was thinking about those answers i'm
saying you don't look like a criminal
when i ask you a question you don't be
good i'm just i'm just like i i i feel
like a more like logical thing would be
like uh can i just take a bit of time to
think about this answer yeah no no no
because you've got to seem confident
yeah i'd be like that is a fantastic
question yeah think of the way to
appropriately answer that no you you
what if you combine it right yeah yeah
yeah you gotta combine it with the water
that's the fantasy
what if what if the water doesn't give
you enough time
are you just like downing an entire
[ __ ] jug of war you're sitting there
for like 10 minutes just going they're
like gone
like what's your fault
your favorite food is oh [ __ ]
well what if or what if you know you're
just like
you get off of the water right and
you're just like really thirsty and then
you get to that really difficult
question you're just like
[ __ ]
like what do i do now
never told me sir you've gone through
three litres of water during this
interview are you are you feeling okay i
have to say like 99 of life hacks or
some [ __ ] i just immediately forget and
never remember and we'll never ever
practically use yeah yeah yeah i've seen
so many others especially when it comes
to like [ __ ] survival like these
these kinds of like hacks or like advice
you see on tick tocks like i don't know
if we've ever talked about this on
podcast i think we've only talked about
it in private but like the [ __ ] shaq
financial advice which is an entire
genre
which is which is an entire i think an
entire genre of video on tick tock and
youtube shorts now where it's just like
shaq motivational like life advice and
half of it is just like taking your
paycheck and apparently just ripping it
in half shaq what's the difference
between being rich and being wealthy
it's like when you're rich you do this
but the wealth you do this
is one million likes
thank you shaq i am no longer poor now
i will
the financial advice the problem is with
a lot of these financial advices on like
tick tock and youtube and again i think
shaq is somewhat guilty of this it
assumes you're even making enough money
to save like most people don't aren't
able to save money because like we're
[ __ ] right now yeah you most people
spend all their paycheck that's that's
how it is how do you then go to them and
be like you're just not saving enough
you're just not saving enough that rent
maybe you can get rid of yeah who's
who's living on minimum wage and being
like oh i didn't i shouldn't
are there people who spend it
responsibly hell yeah there are yeah is
that the reason why everyone isn't rich
no
and no
it was just so weird falling into this
hole of just like you know you see these
tik tok with like made up scenarios
where the the perfect life hack for that
scenario will pop up it's always the
same it's one guy is in this part of the
frame and he's like so you want this and
then another guy on the frame probably
with glasses yeah yeah no no that's not
how you do it it's literally always like
that and with the worst acting and the
worst script and then it's like 20
million views and i'm like i'm quitting
much yeah i'm terrible at my job it's
just like an entire [ __ ] genre of
that just takes place in the dharmand
universe you know it's just like the
extended darman universe where you know
everything just works out because of
these because i drank water in my
[ __ ] job interview like
the dcu
man cinematic universe
the one that also just like that i've
been getting a lot recently off youtube
shorts is the ones where like
the ones where they take like you know
those like five minute crafts like
[ __ ] like life hacks and then
there's always some like dude who's like
i'm gonna find out if this is actually
legitimate or not and then they do it
and then they tried themselves and like
okay it was legitimate like for more if
that's the thing that's a thing okay
i've seen so many of those like so many
times where it's like oh if you you know
you get a black marker and you draw it
on your hand and then you take a picture
of it on flash then it apparently zaps
you some [ __ ] like that and and it's
always some guy being like
no it's not factor cap all right let's
try it let's try to figure it out
let's try and figure it out my new
favorite shorts or tic toc uh category
is uh the tick tocks that need way more
explanation as to what's going on but
they the person doing the video does not
offer any explanation as to why they're
doing the thing they're doing
like what there was one time i watched
this tick tock and it was a guy he was
like so here's how i made a case to
carry my ipad farm and then he makes the
case and i i
me and all the other comments were like
why do you have an ipad phone like i
think i've seen that one with the long
case yeah yeah yeah like and like he
made this video just explaining how he
made a case for his ipad farm and i was
like the whole time like
why did you have an ipad phone no no he
makes this ipad farm
to test out if he could make enough
passive income that's it yeah
to justify making an ipad farm and like
me like there are so many layers to this
tick tock that i just want answers to
yeah i'm like question how are you
making this money first of all yeah like
what passive income revenue are you
doing what is this app
have like tons and tons of phones and
you play the same song like on luke oh
wow and then like get revenue from it oh
[ __ ] um but obviously like you've used a
lot of electricity so yeah kind of i
some things like that but yeah i mean
it's again there's so many of these
where they're like we're gonna do this
thing or they're like or you felt like
you just came into like the 90th episode
of the show and you're like what
what is happening and the people making
the videos don't think that like anyone
might need context or something yeah
yeah just one line because like like i
know exactly what you mean though
because they'll always start off the
video with just like last time i made
like a dildo that could fly or something
like that and you guys have been asking
me to make this so i'm going to make it
i'm just like what what what
so many comments saying that you should
make it harder
i'm like what have i missed in the
[ __ ] lore of this you know like how
how far back do i go and the thing is
like it's impossible to like try to like
triangulate this when you click on their
channel or something right because it's
just like it's not always in
chronological order either i don't know
yeah youtube shorts is like
there's so many different like holes you
can slip down into youtube shorts and
[ __ ] tick tock and it's like insane
as well because like
especially with the youtube shorts
because i don't really use tick tock but
like with youtube shorts it knows
exactly what to recommend you next
because it's like oh you spent one extra
second on this one [ __ ] shaq
motivational tick tock that must mean
you want 20 more yeah that's why like
sometimes i'm like if i watch a video
that [ __ ] for too long i'm like
[ __ ] now the algorithm thing now the
algorithm thinks i like this video and
like the next 10 videos will be
something to do with that i'm like i
wish there was some way to just tell
youtube i didn't like the video that
they sent me but unfortunately they
removed the dislike yeah i know
there's a lot of tick tocks or youtube
shorts that i watch and i'm like i hated
this video i want to let them know i
hated it without being an [ __ ]
um
but i can't know so i just have to and
i've already given them my watch time so
i've for all youtube knows that was the
best experience of my life the one that
uh made me fall down the rabbit hole for
youtube shorts for me is uh i saw this
one youtube short of uh
the the founder of 2chan uh because he
has like a live streaming thing yeah and
he like uh he's called hiroyuki but like
he he's very uh you know because he's
the creator of 2chan yeah he's a bit
based in his opinions okay um gamer like
very controversial opinions right based
in the negative yeah based in a negative
term and uh i just watched one because i
couldn't [ __ ] believe the answer and
now
my youtube shorts are just this japanese
dude saying a lot of racist and
controversial [ __ ] and i was like i
don't i didn't i didn't watch this
because i liked it i watched it because
i was trying to process what the [ __ ]
this guy was talking about that's been a
lot of criticism of youtube facebook and
all these platforms they push you to the
more fringes of the content and um yeah
i mean that's one of the parts that's
not so good yeah i think one of the
weirdest ones i've uh the one of the
weirdest genres i've seen that's popped
up recently is we've gotten to the point
where youtube shorts are now
commentating on youtubers oh yeah where
you'll be like lundwig just did this
last week
you won't believe what he did and i'm
just like
this is why saikuno doesn't take
sponsorship
right
i was like
all right cool i guess like it's like mr
beast just sent chocolate bars to every
influencer you know
you know it's like news flash
i don't know it's just it's just so
weird
it's just so weird seeing all these like
new genres and new types of content pop
up um on on i guess like a new for a new
type of platform and everything like
that yeah um but like i don't understand
it at all do you think youtube sure is
gonna stick around do you think it's
gonna get to a point where
i mean
[ __ ] around so yeah
it's you know it's what it is but at the
end of the day the long form content is
still very valuable and that's what
makes the money of course yeah and until
tick-tock find a way to uh properly
monetize that platform without uh paying
their creators way less than uh what
they deserve then uh yeah i think long
long form content
will be king for now that's us that's
that's actually that's what
that's
we have zero bias whatsoever
absolutely zero buyers ridiculously long
videos we only upload six hours of
content a week
but hey that's just a theory a trash
theory
you can do the [ __ ] outro
well look at these patrons wow look at
all these patreon wonderful patrons they
all do this
i'm sure do you do this do you do you
drink water or do you ask for water do
you drink water do you ask for water
during your job interviews i don't
believe
all right well hey if you'd like to
support longer form content like trash
taste then uh consider going to our
patreon patreon.com also follow us on
twitter send us a message with the
subreddit and if you had our face listen
to us on spotify but uh yeah
what was this episode i have no [ __ ]
clue we were like
if we're ever like in the job interview
and we're like the interviewers you know
give me a two liter jog if they ask for
water i'm gonna say no we'll be like
we're like
we don't take things easy here trash
tasting
are you a real sigma i'm doing job
interview hard mode
all right thanks for watching guys all
right bye
[Music]
you